Hallo, guck mal da, der Wubblers ist da, Mordge ist auch am Start, Darkseid hat subscribed,
huge sub.
Oh man Leute, ich sag euch, irgendwie anstrengend in letzter Zeit, na gut, die drei Monate
davor waren auch mega gechillt, wie man so schön sagt, Schwedstream heute, ich bin mir,
ja, ja, aber ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, weil ich hab vorhin gesehen, dass es ein neues
Release von Avalonia gibt, und das wollte ich mir ja auch schon mal seit langer Zeit
angucken, also ich mein, ich mein das hier, Achtung, Achtung, Flashbang, die Seite ist
komplett, Baby, Darkseam, was ist denn da los?
Das ist nämlich ein Cross-Platform-UI-Framework für .NET, und alles, was ich bisher davon
gesehen hab, ich hab noch nicht so viel damit gemacht, ich hab mir das vor Jahren mal kurz
angeguckt und dann nie wieder, ganz ehrlich, alles, was ich bis dahin gesehen hab, erscheint
mir das um Längen angenehmer als Maui, und dementsprechend wollte ich mir das schon mal
ne ganze Weile angucken, ne, was ist das?
Aber ich glaube, da bin ich heute nicht mehr high IQ genug für, mir irgendwas näher anzugucken,
aber das müssen wir unbedingt machen, ich hab sie sogar extra hier oben schon drauf,
in der To-Do-Liste drinne stehen, aber es wär doch wirklich cool, wenn's mal ein gescheites
Cross-Plattform-UI-Framework für .NET gäbe, gäbe, ich gibt, gäbe, weil ansonsten, was
ist die Alternative?
Elektron, sonst fällt mir da nicht allzu viel ein, Flutter auf dem Mobile, Desktop eher
weniger.
Hab ich euch eigentlich schon gesagt, dass mir der YouTube-Algorithmus echt auf den Keks
geht in letzter Zeit, und ich meine nicht den Algorithmus für meine Videos, sondern,
der ist tatsächlich gar nicht übel, wenn man sich die Views anguckt von den letzten,
ok, letzten zwei Videos waren halt nicht so geil, aber davor war alles, alles top, sondern
der Algorithmus auf YouTube, was der mir empfiehlt.
Natürlich kann man jetzt sagen, ja Max, das liegt ja auch daran, was du guckst, aber ich
guck das überhaupt nicht, ich guck das überhaupt nicht, die letzten paar Tage, Alter, ist YouTube
immer der Meinung, ich soll irgendwelchen Beef mit KurenTV mir angucken, ja, MontanaBlackReacts,
Schorio, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die genau heißt, versus KurenTV, Alter, ich will das
überhaupt nicht wissen, das geht mir so unglaublich am Arsch vorbei, aber YouTube ist der Meinung,
doch, doch Max, das interessiert dich, das ist das Geilste, was du dir angucken kannst,
hier, guck mal, noch ein Reaction-Video, das dritte, und dann klicke ich Videos empfohlen,
pass mal auf, pass mal auf, das hört ja nicht auf, das hört ja nicht auf, ich klicke Reaction-Videos
empfohlen von Leuten auf Reaction-Responses auf Reaction, ich kenne keinen der, oder doch,
also vom Namen her, aber nicht wirklich, ich kenne keinen der beteiligten Leute, ich konsumiere
kein Content, Leute, nix, aber YouTube ist immer noch der Meinung, doch Max, das musst du dir
angucken, du, du, Alter, naja, was willst du machen, wenn YouTube das meint, vielleicht gucke
ich das sogar irgendwann mal, dann hat YouTube gewonnen, ja, und Leute, nein, ihr müsst mir
nicht zusammenfassen, um was es in dem Beef geht, ich will es nicht wissen, ich will es nicht wissen,
das interessiert mich nicht, das habe ich davon, weil ich die Insi-Modus, okay, das kann tatsächlich
sein, die Insi-Modus-Videos habe ich ein paar geguckt, aber ist der Insi-Modus nicht auch schon
wieder zwei Jahre oder so her, oder noch länger, das ist doch noch länger her, der Insi-Modus ist
doch schon, also im aktuellen Influencer-Game-Zeiten war das letztes Jahr 1000, Quatsch, das ist doch
länger her als Anfang des Jahres, der Insi-Modus, das ist doch schon ewig her, so ungefähr ist, ja,
weißt du, ich habe ja früher schon nicht verstanden, warum die Omas immer die ganzen Zeitungen in der
Richtung gelesen haben, plus diese ganzen Beef-Videos, das ist quasi so dieses Adel-Drama,
was die Omas früher gelesen haben, für uns auf YouTube quasi, also für die jüngere Generation
auf YouTube, aber mich interessiert es genauso wenig, mir ist das sowas von egal, oh man, aber
YouTube ist der Meinung, nein, Max, das ist genau das, was du gucken willst, gab es doch auch mal
einen, der irgend so eine YouTube-Videoserie gemacht hat, ich habe ein Jahr lang die ganze
Yellow Brass gelesen, da kam doch auch übelster Schwachsinn bei raus, ja, aber das müssen wir uns
tatsächlich im nächsten Stream hier angucken, heute, heute bin ich da nicht high IQ genug für
mir eine Cross-Plattform-UI-Framework für .NET anzugucken, aber nächster Stream, also nächster
Bastel- und Progress-Stream, muss das unbedingt mal sein, dann brauchen wir dann auch den,
wie heißt das Ding, der Speckle-Manager, was so toll ist der Speckle, das ist doch nur eine,
das kann doch nur eine Demo-Anwendung sein, oder, nee, ach nee, das heißt wirklich so,
der Speckle-Manager, Speckle, das hört sich ein bisschen an wie irgendwie Nudelhersteller oder so,
aber anscheinend ist das eine Demo-Anwendung, der Speckle-Manager, das ist eh der Beste,
der ist, der ist extremely underused, dieses Emote, Moment, Moment, warum haben wir keg Java-Skript,
warum haben wir keg Java-Skript zweifach drin, nee, du hast einfach nur doppelt Sachen doppelt
gepostet, so, übrigens, wisst ihr, wo ich mich immer noch extremst debated fühle, ich war ja
einer der blöden Leute damals, die auf Kickstarter, ich erzähle euch nicht die Story von der Hose,
das meine ich nicht, ich habe ja Camelot Unchained, ja doch, so heißt, Camelot Unchained gebackt,
so, und das Spiel ist jetzt, alter, was ist das für ein Buba-Thumbnail hier unten, und die haben
jetzt, glaube ich, die sind jetzt, glaube ich, im elften Jahr oder so von, hat es noch einer von
euch gebackt, zufälligerweise, nur mal, nur mal Frage, so in die Runde, vielleicht war ja noch
jemand so blöd wie ich, gerade Oldschool-MMO-Spieler haben das, haben das eventuell gebackt, kann ja
sein, so, also diese Kampagne auf Kickstarter, die gab es, ja, zuletzt aktualisiert, 2015, das
stimmt aber nicht, also, ja, doch, aktualisiert, aber reingegangen in Kickstarter sind die, glaube
ich, 2012 oder irgendwie sowas, weiß gar nicht, ob man das, ob man das hier irgendwie sieht, sieht
man das bei Kickstarter irgendwo, wann ein Projekt live gegangen ist, FAQ, ne, ja, Updates waren es
vielleicht, letztes Update 2015, ja, hier, erstes, erstes Update, ach Gott, wisst ihr, das ist auch
ein Trend im Internet, der mich persönlich nervt, warum, jetzt, jetzt, ich hab, ich, jetzt mal,
ernst gemeinte UI-Design-Frage, warum gibt es hier keine Pages, warum muss ich jetzt, wenn ich das
erste Update sehen will, hier erstmal 500 Mal auf weiter klicken, ne, also, was ist das für ein
Schwachsinn, wer hat sich, wer von den krassen HiIQ-Webdesignern hat sich überlegt, das ist so geil, das
müssen wir standardmäßig etablieren, das machen nämlich total viele Seiten so, ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht noch, das ist so laut, ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch, es gab mal Seiten im Internet,
es gab mal Seiten im Internet, da konnte man tatsächlich, wenn man einen Post aufgemacht hat,
unten, da gab es unten so eine, so eine Seite, so 512 Seiten, da konnte man da tatsächlich sagen,
ah, Moment, da hat doch jemand was vor zwei Wochen reingepostet, was war das nochmal, und dann ist
man runtergegangen auf Seite 35, Seite 37, ok, Datum passt, Seite 38 hat es gefunden, aber nein,
das gibt es nicht mehr, heutzutage ist Webdesign, nice ist Webdesign, 500 Mal auf weiter klicken,
ich flame wieder über aktuelles Webdesign, das geht, zumindest, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte,
ich fühle mich immer noch extrem gebatet, ich hab den Fehler gemacht und war letztens mal wieder,
also ich hab damals auch die Early Access Version mal installiert und so, da gab es ja noch gar nichts
und das Schlimme ist, dass das quasi immer noch genauso stand, zumindest ich hab den Fehler gemacht,
ich bin letztens auf Reddit gegangen, auf das Subreddit von denen, und die Posten, und das,
passt mal auf, ich muss mich da jetzt einfach mal kurz zu auskotzen, vielleicht für alle,
die es gebackt haben, so, und genau, hier, Newsletter, ihr müsst euch vorstellen, passt mal auf,
Mailchimp, was, ok, also, ich will es jetzt nicht mit euch lesen, ich will euch aber mal was zeigen,
dass ihr vielleicht das Ausmaß des Gbates und der Unfähigkeit etwas einschätzen könnt, warum
mich das so nervt, also, die sind als Kickstarter Projekt 2013 an den Start gekommen, haben gesagt,
sie wollen ein MMO machen, das sind die gleichen Leute, oder zumindest der Erfinder von, oder einer
der Miterfinder von Dark Age of Camelot, ein MMO, was ich persönlich quasi, boah, ich spiele es ja immer
noch ab und zu auf Free Shards, ja, ich spiele das immer wieder, seit Release, immer wieder, jahrelang
habe ich das gespielt, so, und ich dachte mir, wann wäre das geil, richtiges Hardcore-Boomer-MMO,
euch wird das wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil, wenn ihr, wenn ihr MMOs kennt, sagen wir mal,
World of Warcraft mit den ersten paar Addons und neuer wahrscheinlich nicht gefallen, außer ihr
seid Hardcore-PvP-Spieler, dann vielleicht schon, zumindest, die sind auf Kickstarter gegangen und
haben zwei Millionen oder so eingesammelt, aber es war damals schon klar, es gab zusätzliche,
zusätzliche, ja, Funding-Runden mit irgendwelchen Sponsoren, nee, Publisher oder irgendwelche
Geldgeber, nennen wir es mal Geldgeber, so, und dann habe ich mir gedacht, wär das nicht geil,
wenn es die Leute quasi mit der ursprünglichen Darkvision heute nochmal ein Game machen würden,
ich habe das gebacked, ich habe das, ich habe, ich glaube, ich habe sogar 500 Dollar oder so
gebacked, weiß gar nicht mehr, was die Tiers waren, also ich habe Early, Early Access gebacked und
alles und Beta und Alpha und Geschiss, kann durchaus sein, dass ich sogar 500 Dollar gebacked
habe, so, und jetzt waren die, also die entwickeln das Game seit 10 Jahren, über 10 Jahre, über 10
Jahre, das ist, ohne Scheiß, genau, genau so fühlte man sich da, so, also ihr müsst den Hinterkopf
behalten, wir reden hier über ein MMO, was 10 Jahre in Entwicklung ist, 10 Jahre plus in Entwicklung,
so, und jetzt, und jetzt kommt der Newsletter zum aktuellen Entwicklungsstand, haltet euch fest,
der Newsletter, wir reden über ein Spiel, was über 10 Jahre in Entwicklung ist und eigentlich schon
2016 oder so hätte erscheinen sollen oder 2015, Achtung, Moment, also erstmal sieht man nix und
es gibt Concept Arts, das ist nicht Ingame-Grafik, Concept Arts, Concept Arts und irgendwelche komischen
Crafting Stats, what, Alter, das war's, das war's, die überwickeln, die entwickeln über 10 Jahre an
diesem Game und es gibt ein Concept Arts, das ist doch echt hängen geblieben, pass mal auf, guck auf 39, die
anderen Dinge sind übrigens, die anderen Dinge sind übrigens, genau, Concept Arts, oh, toll, ein Ingame-Screenshot,
hui, ui, ui und wir sehen Grafik von dem Game wie vor 25 Jahren, geil, ja, also ganz ehrlich, ich fühle
mich so extrem gebatet von denen, guckt euch das mal an, also, das Game ist 10 Jahre in Entwicklung, es gibt
keine Fertig-, also es gibt noch nicht mal, noch nicht mal Gameplay, was funktioniert, das muss man sich echt mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, Alter, kein Gameplay, kein-, es gibt nichts eigentlich in dem Spiel, es gibt, es
gibt paar Ideen-Ansätze, das war's, na gut, zumindest, da haben sie mich richtig, richtig hardcore gebatet,
was das angeht, das ist, das ist, das ist, glaube ich, das Game, warum ich nichts mehr auf-, also, ich will's nicht
ausschließen, dass ich nochmal was auf Kickstarter backe, aber das ist das, warum ich gesagt habe, ich backe, backe
erstmal nichts mehr auf Kickstarter und ich hab seitdem eigentlich auch nichts mehr gebackt, ich glaube, das mit der
Hose war noch davor, ja, ich muss noch mehr donaten, mach mal, mach mal einen Kickstarter, wenn du einen Oldschool
MMO auf die Reihe stellst, was mich anspricht, bin ich dabei. So, und jetzt eine Sache muss ich aber noch dazu
sagen, bevor wir-, bevor wir das Thema abhaken, sonst, sonst reg ich mich da zu sehr drüber auf, eine Sache muss ich
noch sagen, und zwar, ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass die von Anfang an Leute scammen wollten, ich glaube, die hatten
von Anfang an-, ich meine-, wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an, ah, da ist er, das ist der Ober-Scammer, ja, die hatten
ja auch nur Concept Arts und sowas, ich frag mich, wie der Typ das überhaupt geschafft hat, nur eine Handvoll
Programmierer über 10 Jahre zu beschäftigen dafür, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, also, Yazi Yuzu, dankeschön für den
Sub und danke an die ganzen anderen Subs, die ich eventuell übersehen habe, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ja, also,
genau, also eine Sache wollte ich noch sagen, ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass die von Anfang an versucht haben, Leute
zu scammen, das glaube ich nicht, ich glaube, die hatten-, ne, ich habe nichts übersehen, gut, ich glaube, die hatten
wirklich die Absicht, ein MMO zu machen, die-, die-, die wollten nicht scammen, also nicht ursprünglich, aber es ist
dann nach und nach halt durch wahrscheinlich Missmanagement komplett aus dem Rahmen gelaufen und halt zu
irgendwie einem Scam-Game geworden, was mir echt leid tut, ich hätte mich wirklich gefreut über ein neues Dark im-,
im, sag mal, im Geiste, ja, und zu der Story mit der Hose, ich will euch nicht 500 Mal die Recycle-Story erzählen,
Faded? Was? Verboten? Ähm, also, zu der Sache mit der Hosenummer in zwei Sätzen, ich-, ich habe-, ich habe meine Hose
gebacked auf Kickstarter, ich glaube, da habe ich auch 200 Dollar oder so gebacked, weil ich die-, oder 120 Dollar oder
sowas gebacked, weil ich die Idee cool fand und zwar, ich kann es euch mal kurz zeigen, das war eine-, das war eine Hose,
die war angeblich dreckabweisend, weil da Silber eingewebt war oder sowas, ich habe mich davon-, ich habe mich davon
überzeugen lassen, guckt, die zeigen dann-, guckt, die zeigen dann, okay, jetzt schüttelt-, schüttelt der Kaffee auf die Hose,
oh, das perlt ab und sowas, also, ich-, ich fand das damals, das ist noch-, das ist noch länger her, wo das hier am
Schau, guck mal, letztes Update, was? 2018? Moment, das ist erst fünf Jahre her, wo die was zuletzt aktualisiert haben, wait a
minute, der Stützer, ich-, also, ich habe bis heute nichts bekommen und da-, da habe ich mich damals von überzeugen lassen,
das war auch so in den-, das ist auch schon ganz lange her, ja, da habe ich mich damals von überzeugen lassen und dachte mir,
ey, geile Sache, die backst du und selbst, wenn du halt nur eine Hose bekommst, die halt dann im Schrank rumhängt oder gar
nicht, die Idee fand ich cool und ich habe mit-, ich habe hier so mit dem Tier gebackt, dass ich sogar noch so ein-, so ein
abweisendes T-Shirt bekomme, hier irgendwie sowas, hier Jeans und-, und ein T-Shirt und so, fand ich-, fand ich eine coole
Sache, aber da wurde ich halt richtig gescampt, es gab nie eine Hose und die haben das Geld genommen, ich glaube, die wurden
dann nachher auch verklagt oder es haben, es haben zumindest ein paar versucht, sie zu verklagen, die haben das Geld genommen
und sind abgehauen, also, man hat nie was davon gehört, es ist auch nicht bekannt, ob die überhaupt jemals versucht haben,
dieses Produkt herzustellen, also es ist nicht wie bei Camelot Unchained, dass es ernsthafte Absicht-, Absichten hatte,
dass die in ernsthafter Absicht ein Game zu entwickeln, die wollten anscheinend wirklich nur scammen, da bin ich halt voll
reingetappt damals, der Scam-Train ist am Start, Don Quijon 1, Hog Subscription, das stimmt, aber in dem Fall würde ich sagen,
das ist einer der MMO-Pioniere schlechthin gewesen, der das machen wollte, also von dem würde ich erwarten-, und der hat auch
schon Millionen MMOs gemacht, also Budget-technisch, von dem würde ich erwarten eigentlich, dass er das besser
weiß, und er hat ja auch gesagt, er steckt Selbstgeld rein, plus hat Funding-Geld noch, also, wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht,
dass Camelot Unchained ursprünglich ein Scam war, und was die sich-, also woran-, wir wissen es natürlich nicht,
also ich glaube, es ist daran gescheitert, dass die sich komplett-, dass die komplett mismanaged haben, dass die
Feature-Creep as fuck hatten, und überhaupt-, überhaupt kein Fokus auf das eigentliche Game, und der Meinung waren,
wie, wir sollen das-, wir könnten das doch mit Unreal und Unity bauen, nee, nee, lass uns mal lieber eigenen Campel bauen,
dass wir da irgendwie andere Sachen machen können, letztendlich ist da nie was rausgekommen, und um die Leute noch mal
richtig aufzuregen, die Camelot Unchained gebackt haben, haben die dann irgendwann so ein billiges Tower-Defense-Game
oder irgendwie sowas auf Steam released, als Early Access, was zu seinen Hochzeiten, glaube ich, fünf Spieler hatte,
und nicht weiterentwickelt wird, wo sich alle nur gefragt haben, warum steckt ihr da überhaupt Zeit rein,
also ihr habt acht Jahre Verspätung mit eurem Main-Game, naja, das ist cool, das kenne ich, das ist dieses Open-Source-Warcraft,
also nicht MMO-Strategie-Spiel, Warcraft, Daze Codes, dankeschön für den Sub, dazu kann ich bloß sagen,
nice, ni-ni-nice, extremely nice, wie schwer ist es, so Game-Entwicklungen in 2023, wie zum Beispiel 2023-,
also, 2023 Quake entwickeln, das kann wahrscheinlich heute ein einzelner Entwickler, ein Spiel mit genug Zeit,
ja, ähm, und nötige Motivation, und Ehrgeiz, und Können, also ein Spiel wie Quake zu entwickeln in der heutigen Zeit ist, glaube ich,
gar nichts, also, ich rede jetzt wirklich, ein Spiel wie, grafisch wie Quake, vom Umfang her wie Quake,
ich glaube, das kann heute theoretisch ein einzelner Entwickler, wenn er eben auf Sachen zurückgreift, die es schon gibt,
also erstens auf die Game-Entwicklung-Experience der letzten 30 Jahre, auf aktuelle Engines, mit denen er sich hoffentlich auskennt,
ähm, auf, auf, auf fertige Funktionalität, die diese Engines bieten, eventuell die ein oder anderen Assets,
und im Endeffekt, eigentlich muss er bloß die Level bauen, aber das kann es natürlich die Frage, ja,
also, er könnte das sicherlich machen, von den, von den, von der Technik her,
ob er die Skills hat, gute Level zu bauen, dafür weiß ich nicht,
aber es gibt ja schon Spiele, die, es gibt ja schon ähnliche Sachen, die von ganz kleinen Teams entwickelt wurden,
das läuft ja heutzutage eher so unter dem, unter dem Begriff Boomer-Shooter, und da gibt's, da gibt's ein paar,
die von, die von ganz kleinen Teams entwickelt wurden,
also mit der aktuellen Technik ist heute ein Spiel wie Quake,
einfacher umzusetzen, weil es einfach ganz viele fertige Sachen gibt, und übrigens,
mich, mich würde nicht wundern, wenn, aber da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob das stimmt,
ich würde nicht wundern, wenn Teile aus dem Quake-Source-Code heute in ganz vielen Games noch drinnen wären,
ich, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wer damals alles von wem irgendwie kopiert hat,
bzw. die Möglichkeit dazu hatte,
aber die waren so einer, so früh am Start mit Doom und Quake,
die mussten sich zwangsläufig viele Sachen so pioniermäßig neu ausdenken,
und ich will nicht wissen, wie viel davon abgeguckt wurde,
gut, ich mein, das in der Source-Engine garantiert, also da wette ich mit euch, Leute,
da wette ich mit euch, in der Source-Engine werden garantiert heute noch
1 zu 1 Zeilen drinstehen, wie sie aus Quake und Doom kommen, 100 pro,
vielleicht jetzt nicht super viel, aber mit Sicherheit sind da noch Sachen drinnen von damals,
wie das jetzt bei, bei Unity und Unreal aussieht, kann ich nicht sagen, die haben ja offiziell nix damit zu tun,
aber ich weiß nicht, wie viel man damals voneinander kopiert hat,
aber zumindest in der Source-Engine, in der Source-Engine sind heute immer noch
garantiert Zeilen drin, die auch schon in Quake drinnen waren,
und in Call of Duty wahrscheinlich auch,
in Call of Duty, in der Call of Duty-Engine wahrscheinlich auch,
obwohl das ja alles mal angeblich komplett neu entwickelt wurde, aber ich glaube, Teile haben immer noch kopiert,
also alle Games, die in irgendeiner Weise auf den alten idSoft-Spielen aufsetzen,
also entweder auf der Source-Engine aufbauen, oder eben irgendeine Variante der, der idTech,
wie hieß die Dinger, idTech-Dings-Engine verwendet haben und weiterentwickelt haben,
so wie Call of Duty und auch viele andere,
ich, ich gehe davon aus, dass da heute immer noch Sachen, die damals in Quake standen, immer noch drinne stehen.
Nicht so viel, aber die ein oder anderen Zeilen bestimmt noch.
Das stimmt schon, deswegen finde ich es immer lustig, wenn es Leute gibt, die sagen,
oh, mein erstes Projekt wird ein MMO, na, das ist ein bisschen, ist vielleicht ein bisschen,
wie soll man sagen, so außerhalb der eigenen Gewichtsklasse,
aber jemand, der schon MMOs mit Millionenbudget hergestellt hat,
und eines, einer der MMO-Pioniere quasi war,
dem habe ich das eher zugetraut, dass er weiß, was er da macht,
aber offensichtlich nicht, sonst wäre Camelot Unchained heute schon draußen,
und nicht über 10 Jahre in der Entwicklung, und es gibt nicht mal ein ordentliches,
ja, Gameplay, es gibt eigentlich nichts in dem Spiel,
und ich, ich bezweifle auch, dass es überhaupt jemals rauskommen wird.
Also, wenn das rauskommen wird, dann nur,
wenn, wenn irgendein Geldgeber oder irgendjemand finden, der dann auch gleichzeitig die Führung übernimmt,
aber dann bleibt wahrscheinlich von der eigenen Vision nicht mehr viel übrig,
aber die Frage ist dann auch, wer will das Game haben?
Ich meine, das sieht aus wie von, das sieht wirklich aus wie von 2013, das Game.
Wie ein schlecht aussehendes MMO von 2013.
Also, ich glaube, woran es scheitern würde, wenn Leute heute Quake machen, ist eher das Level-Design.
Wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass die eben fertige Funktionen und Bestandteile
aus dem Asset-Store, die die Engine-Beat und so benutzen,
weil ich gehe davon aus, du wirst heute sowohl bei Unity als auch bei Unreal
schon fertige Controller und Logik-Blöcke finden,
die ein, die ziemlich genau das Quake- und Doom-Feeling simulieren.
Also, wenn man das haben will, ja.
Garantiert wird es das geben.
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich eines der ersten Fingerübungen sein,
eines jeden Game-Engine-Plug-In-Verkäufers,
mal irgendwie sowas zu bauen, was halt seinem Lieblingsspiel nahekommt.
Und das wird es geben.
Aber das Level-Design stelle ich mir tatsächlich schwierig vor.
Ich meine, wenn man es natürlich eins zu eins kopiert, ist klar, aber da geht es ja nicht drum.
Da einen guten Fluss hinzubekommen, ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich was,
wo auch heute viele Entwickler Probleme hätten.
Die Hose ist nicht atmungsaktiv, das weiß ich nicht, weil die Hose gab es ja nie.
Also mich hat noch keiner versucht, auf diese Art und Weise zu scammen.
Mein Opa haben sie aber mal gescammt.
Da waren so zwei Lederjacken-Verkäufer an der Tür und die haben ihm sonst was erzählt.
Am Ende hat er die auch noch reingelassen
und da haben sie ihm Geld aus dem Schlafzimmer geklaut.
Der eine hat gesagt, der muss mal aufs Klo und der andere hat mein Opa voll geschwätzt
und ist hinten rum durch die Wohnung gegangen im Schlafzimmer
und hat ihm irgendwie 800 Euro oder so geklaut.
Den haben sie richtig gescammt, aber das ist halt auch das Asi-Zeug, gell?
Mein Opa war damals ja schon über 80.
Und dass sie immer die Omas und Opas scammen müssen.
Und Leute, ihr könnt jetzt weird schampen, so viel ihr wollt.
Wartet mal ab, bis ihr 80 oder gar 85 plus seid.
Übrigens, mein Opa wäre vor ein paar Wochen 100 geworden.
Fällt mir gerade so auf.
Ich hab mal irgendwann...
Ich hab mal irgendwann mit meinem Opa...
Was zum...
Warum findet man da nix?
Ich hab mal irgendwann mit meinem Opa ein Video gemacht.
Und das Video...
Also, ganz ehrlich, das Video lohnt sich nicht wirklich anzugucken.
Ich versuche die ganze Zeit...
Ich versuche...
Warte mal, ich hol kurz die Musik aus.
Ich versuche die ganze Zeit, meinen Opa ein bisschen dazu zu bringen, was zu erzählen.
Und er will halt nicht, ne?
Er sagt die ganze Zeit, ich stehe nicht so auf Gelaber und sowas.
20.000, 20.000 Leute, das gibt Sachen, das ist...
Da gucken deutlich mehr.
Du musst immer davor achten.
Du hörst das, der hat halt so überhaupt keinen Bock.
Ich möchte jetzt bloß ungefähr...
5 Minuten ist ja ein schönes, spannendes Thema, was man mal unbedingt besprechen sollte hier.
Weiß ich nicht.
Der hat überhaupt keinen Bock.
Aber trotzdem, irgendwie haben wir trotzdem 10 Minuten drüber gelabert.
Weiß ich nicht.
Und der erzählt ja dann so...
Ich bin kein Freund von dieser Internetlaberei oder sowas.
Ja.
Ja, bin ich heute drüber froh, dass ich mit meinem Opa ein Video aufgenommen habe.
Kann mich immer wieder anhören, sich drüber lustig machen.
So nach dem Motto, guck mal an hier.
Damals war...
Ich mein, der war schon immer übelst stur, ja?
Den Namen hab ich schon mal gehört.
Was macht der denn?
360 No Scope HD.
Kann sein, dass ich von dem schon mal was geguckt hab.
Sagt mir aber nix jetzt.
Ja.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich mein, vielleicht war das utopisch, dass die den MMO hinbekommen.
Aber ich mein, der Typ weiß eigentlich...
Also, wusste eigentlich, wie es geht.
Hatte ein bisschen Funding und wollte Privatgeld reinstecken.
Und hat angeblich ja noch Geldgeber gehabt.
Also, das klang schon pausibel.
Sonst hätte ich nicht 500 Dollar oder sowas gebackt damals.
Gut, in eurem Bereich wundert mich das auch nicht.
Also, gerade bei so Embedded Sachen oder Maschinensteuerung.
Da tauscht du ja auch nicht einfach mal Sachen aus, von denen du weißt, dass das gut funktioniert.
So nach dem Motto, ah!
Das ist nicht nach modernsten Best-Practice-Sachen entstanden in der neuen Hype-Technologie.
Lass das mal kurz neu entwickeln.
Und dann am Ende dreht sich der Roboter links rum anstatt rechts rum oder sowas.
Nicht so die cleverste Idee.
Es ist wahrscheinlich so, wie die NASA auch nicht auf die Idee kommen würde.
Den Code für das Ausklinken von den Armen an den Raketen.
Jetzt durch irgendwelchen hippen JavaScript-Kram zu ersetzen.
Mir reicht es ja schon.
Mir reicht es ja schon, dass...
Leute, wisst ihr...
Wisst ihr, was da im Hintergrund läuft bei SpaceX?
Wisst ihr, was da läuft auf den Displays?
Erdchat. Tatsächlich, ihr habt recht.
Das ist so eine Art Elektron, was da läuft.
Das ist JavaScript.
Muss ich mal vorstellen.
Wenn die Amis demnächst mal wieder auf den Mond fliegen wollen oder werden...
Ist ja noch ein bisschen in Verzögerung.
Dann fliegen wir mit Elektron und JavaScript auf den Mond.
Okay, es gab für die meisten Sachen, glaube ich, noch Knöpfe und andere Sachen.
Aber es ist Chrome und JavaScript.
Das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Dass wir mit JavaScript mal ins Weltall fliegen.
Aber den Vorteil, den die haben, ist, die hatten halt noch nix, was funktioniert.
Die konnten halt von Anfang an, die konnten halt das neu entwickeln.
Die standen gar nicht vor dem Problem.
Machen wir es neu oder nehmen wir was Altes?
Aber dass die NASA jetzt nicht auf die Idee kommt.
Lass uns mal kurz den Code, der für das Ausklinken der Rakete an der Startarme zuständig ist.
Lass es mal kurz neu entwickeln.
Was ist die neueste Hype-Sprache?
Zick oder so?
Das kann ich schon nachvollziehen.
Ja, ByteStrike, da haben wir letztens ein Video drüber geguckt.
ByteStrike, ich hab übrigens...
Du wurdest geleakt.
Hab ich dir das eigentlich schon gesagt?
Wir werden laufend auf YouTube nämlich irgendwelche Videos empfohlen,
wo die Leute sich untereinander biefen.
So KuchenTV bieft sich mit sonst was.
Und ich hab ein Video angeklickt.
Obwohl ich das überhaupt nicht sehen will.
Ich hab mich ja am Anfang des Streams schon drüber ausgelassen.
Ich hab ein Video angeklickt und da lief links ein Twitch-Chat.
Ja, genau, ByteStrike.
Da lief links ein Twitch-Chat.
Und auf einmal sehe ich ByteStrike in dem Twitch-Chat.
Liegt.
Hab ich auch gedacht, ey, wie kommt mir der Name bekannt vor?
Ich weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist das, was ich gemeint hab vorhin.
Ich krieg nicht nur die Beef-Videos empfohlen,
dass Leute sich...
Nein, ich krieg auch von Leuten...
Also ich kenn die ja alle nicht.
Nicht wirklich, ich verfolge den Content nicht, ja?
Also ich krieg Reactions auf...
Also von Leuten, die damit nichts zu tun haben,
die reakten auf die Reaction von einer Conter-Reaction auf seine Reaction.
Alter, das ist so abgedreht mittlerweile auf YouTube.
Und mich interessiert es halt so absolut gar nicht.
Das ist wirklich Reaction vierter Ordnung, ja.
Jasper, danke schön für den Sub.
Wann beefst du dich mit dem einen Typen aus dem YouTube-Kommentar?
Mit welchem? Ich könnte mich da mit ein paar beefen.
Aber beefen mit Leuten aus YouTube-Kommentaren ist blöd.
Ich müsste mich eigentlich mit anderen YouTubern beefen.
Und im Zweifelsfall am besten natürlich mit welchen,
die nicht nur mehr Abos haben,
sondern auch welche, die viel mehr Views haben.
Also es bringt nichts, wenn man sich mit einem Channel beeft,
der mehr Abos hat, aber den seit fünf Jahren oder so keiner mehr guckt.
Du musst dich mit Leuten beefen,
wo aktuell richtig die Leute scharf drauf sind,
wenn man sich mit denen beeft.
Und dann...
Und was...
Was ist das für ein Comment?
Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Warte mal, ich muss mal hier im Stream aufmachen.
Jasper, danke für den Sub.
Der da, okay, lass mal das Comment lesen kurz.
Also...
Okay.
Unter welchem YouTube-Video war das?
Dass das Video...
Ah, das ist mein letztes Video, wo es darum ging,
dieses, wie man eine Gehaltserhöhung bekommt oder so was.
Okay, also, was, was, meine Herren?
Du sagst, es gibt für jeden die Chance, etwas zu dechseln.
Zu deichseln?
Zu wechseln.
Also, ich arbeite im Einzelhandel und habe in fünf Jahren
noch nie einen von den Gurus gesehen.
Hä?
Wait a minute.
Moment mal.
Auf was?
Ich verstehe den Zusammenhang zum Video gerade nicht.
Wartet mal.
Ich vermute mal, das gehört...
Ich vermute mal, das gehört dazu.
Okay, wie heißt der Typ?
Double.
Ich glaube, dem habe ich doch auch geantwortet.
Ich kann nichts dafür, dass du deinen Job nicht magst.
Ja, da ist er doch.
Da ist er doch.
Also.
Okay.
Äh.
Meine Güte, warum ist...
Alter!
Warum...
Oh Gott, warum ist...
Warum ist das so kacke, YouTube, man?
Ich kann das ja nicht mal vergrößern.
Okay.
Du sagst, es gibt für jeden die Chance, etwas zu wechseln.
Aber ich arbeite im Einzelhandel und habe in fünf Jahren noch nie
einen von den Gurus gesehen.
Welche Gurus?
Allgemein habe ich schon...
...viele Videos von dir gesehen,
aber alles, was du erzählst,
scheint sich im IT-Bereich abzuspielen.
Ja, nicht untrue.
Also würde ich schon sagen,
ja, natürlich spielt sich bei mir vieles im IT-Bereich ab.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil ich im IT-Bereich arbeite.
Seit 20...
Naja, nicht ganz, aber nicht übertreiben.
Seit 15 Jahren.
Und...
Ja.
Soll ich darüber reden, wie es als Wurstfachverkäufer ist?
Ich meine,
es ist doch sinnvoll, wenn ich über das rede,
wovon ich weiß,
was ich sage, oder?
Warum soll ich über random Sachen reden?
Ich meine, die Sachen sich daraus...
...zu transferieren,
ja, wenn ich sage,
okay, man könnte das ja mal in einem Daily-Meeting erzählen.
Wenn jemand kein Daily-Meeting hat,
dass er aus der Essenz meiner Aussage mitnimmt,
ja,
die Sachen mal ansprechen.
Das muss ja nicht zwangsläufig auf einem Daily-Meeting sein,
wenn ich Daily-Meeting gesagt habe.
Okay, lass mal.
Im Bereich abzuführen.
Jemand wie mich quasi wertlos.
Was?
Scheint sich mal die...
...jemand wie mich quasi wertlos?
Hä?
Das habe ich in dem Video nicht...
...irgendwie auch nicht mal ansatzweise irgendwie...
...irgendwas in dieser Richtung erzählt.
Ich komme mir da immer vor wie ein Mensch zweiter Klasse.
Bei uns gibt es keine Meetings oder so.
Ja, aber es gibt doch sicherlich irgendwelche Abstimmungstermine,
irgendwelche Schichtplanungssachen,
irgendwelche Dinger so.
Und sei es so, man sitzt morgens mit seinem Chef,
bevor die Arbeit losgeht mal irgendwo.
Irgendwann wird doch mal Austausch stattfinden untereinander, oder?
Oder was weiß ich.
To stop.
Das gilt für den Großteil der Bevölkerung.
Für uns gibt es das Hamsterrad.
Das war es.
Also hör mal endlich auf, so selbstverständlich von deinem Job zu reden.
Ich rede halt von meinem Job.
Vor was soll ich denn sonst reden?
Krass, krass toller Job, den du da hast.
Ist klar, aber laber nicht irgendwas,
dass deine Tipps für jeden gelten.
Weil das ist nicht so.
Sei froh, so einen geilen Job zu haben.
Halt die Fresse, du Spast.
Das wusste man hat richtig gemerkt,
man hat richtig gemerkt, wie sie angepisst hat am Ende, oder?
Halt die Fresse, du Spast.
Ja gut, okay.
Hey, wisst ihr was?
Es stört mich nicht so, dass mich das mittlerweile großartig stört.
Ich habe mir noch geschrieben,
ich kann nichts dafür, wenn dein Job kacke findest.
Und er hat dann auch gar nicht...
Okay, er sagt gar nicht, dass sein Job kacke ist.
Okay, ich weiß nicht.
Aber irgendwie, also...
Er sagt es nicht genauso,
aber es liest sich schon ziemlich stark danach,
dass er seinen Job kacke findet, oder?
Also das hat überhaupt nichts mit der Realität zu tun,
was ich erzähle und in seinem Job ist das so.
Es ist vielleicht in meinem tollen Job so, aber ihm nicht.
Ja gut, da kann ich jetzt ja auch nichts für.
Aber trotzdem.
Also ich denke, wenn man sich das Video angeguckt hat,
klar, man merkt,
und das ist jetzt mal halbwegs seriös zu versuchen noch,
da, hups, Mikrofon gehauen,
so zu sagen,
klar, ich denke, natürlich weiß man bei meinen Videos,
dass es um IT-Jobs geht.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz,
so die Essenz dessen, was ich gesagt habe,
bin ich mir sicher,
lässt sich auf sehr viele Berufe übertragen.
Das muss nicht nur IT
oder nicht nur irgendwelche Sesselfurzer-Jobs sein.
Das geht in vielen Bereichen.
Natürlich hast du vielleicht im Einzelhandel
oder irgendwie in anderen Bereichen,
wenn du hier jetzt Rohre verlegen gehst oder sowas,
bestimmt kein Daily Scrum Meeting.
Aber du sitzt bestimmt auch mal irgendwie zusammen mit den Leuten
oder hast irgendwelche Besprechungen für den Tag,
irgendwelche Planungen,
irgendwelche Weiterbildungen,
irgendwelchen Austausch mit dem Chef.
Und da kann man durchaus Verbesserungsvorschläge anbringen
oder aber halt auch sagen,
okay, hier, die und die Sachen sind gut gelaufen und das nicht
und wir müssen uns mal über das...
Hey, und wenn dir dann so ein Typ vor dir hast,
der sagt, alter, laber nicht mit mir,
halt die Fresse und die Arbeiten,
ja, dann scheint es ja wohl doch ein Kackjob zu sein.
Und natürlich gibt es Kackjobs,
aber da kann ich ja nichts dran ändern.
Das müssen die Leute schon selbst machen.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Okay, er war angepisst.
Ja, kann immer mal sein.
Sag mal, was sind aktuell so deine Hauptaufgaben auf der Arbeit?
Da könnte ich tatsächlich mal ein neues Video zu machen.
Ich habe heute einen Fehler gemacht auf der Arbeit, Leute.
Ich habe mal wieder den alten Fehler gemacht,
in den ich schon öfters reingetappt bin in meinem Leben.
Ich habe zu viel gesagt.
Zu manchen Sachen.
Und zwar...
He doesn't know, he lacks critical information.
Und zwar, also folgendermaßen.
Wir hatten heute oder besser gesagt die letzten paar Tage
hatten wir so eine Veranstaltung für neue Mitarbeiter.
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe es seit 1. April dort angefangen.
Und ich meine, ich bin jetzt drei Monate da,
aber die Veranstaltung gibt es nicht so oft.
Und ja, die war jetzt halt.
Gut.
Sekunde, Leute.
Ich brauche ein bisschen Abkühlung gerade.
Und ihr müsst mich auch unbedingt mal mehr ans Trinken erinnern.
Ich habe schon jetzt 45 Minuten gelabert, ohne was zu trinken.
Battlefield 4 ist immer noch ein grandioses Game, das stimmt.
Jetzt habe ich schon was getrunken.
Jetzt ist es too late.
Das wirkt ja nicht.
Was ist denn das Gegenteil von retroaktiv?
Proaktiv.
Das wirkt nicht proaktiv, die Sachen, wenn ihr das jetzt donatet.
Da denke ich trotzdem in fünf Minuten nicht dran.
Ist vor allem eine Workstation eigentlich kostenlos?
Nee.
Du kriegst aber günstige Keys.
Und Chainlore, erspar den Mods, dass sie dich timeouten müssen heute.
Keck, wait.
Also, okay.
Bisschen Abkühlung am Start.
Also, was war die Sache heute?
Ich hatte heute quasi eine Veranstaltung.
Das lief die letzten paar Tage über schon.
Da wurden halt Dinge erzählt.
Und dann war auch jemand dort, der hat halt erzählt,
wie bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber so,
wie nennt man das so,
der Verbesserungsprozess und
wie innovativ man ist und was man alles macht,
um so am Puls der Zeit zu bleiben und sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, hat einer einen Vortrag drüber gehalten.
Und ich habe dann den Fehler gemacht,
dazu ein paar Sachen zu fragen.
So.
Das erste, was ich gefragt habe, ist,
okay, was kommt denn da so auf einen zu,
wenn man sich da jetzt beispielsweise einträgt?
Also, Essenz aus dem Vortrag ist,
Essenz aus dem Vortrag ist gewesen,
es gibt so ein globales, super, ja,
Future-IT-Innovations-Team.
Das machen die alle während ihrer normalen Arbeit.
Und die haben, glaube ich, drei oder vier,
die das quasi hauptberuflich machen.
Und dann haben sie noch Mitarbeiter aus allen möglichen Bereichen.
So.
Und ich habe den Fehler gemacht, nach diesem Vortrag zu fragen,
okay, was käme denn da so auf einen zu,
wenn man sich auf sowas,
wenn man sich für sowas meldet, ja?
Was kommt dann auf einen zu?
Hat sie das erklärt, auf was auf einen zukommt
und hat schon so nebenbei gesagt,
ach ja, das freut mich ja, dass du da Interesse zeigst.
Und ich dachte mir schon so,
oh, ah, das war jetzt vielleicht schon ein bisschen zu viel,
bisschen zu viel der Rückfrage.
Dann habe ich mich noch weiter dazu hinreißen lassen,
sie anzuschreiben und zu fragen,
ja, wie viel Uhr sind dann solche Termine immer?
Und im Gespräch habe ich dann auch zugegeben,
ja, ich war bei meiner alten Arbeit ja auch schon bei sowas dabei.
Und dann hat sie festgestellt,
ach, Max, ich sehe gerade, das und das ist dein Chef.
Aus deinem Bereich gibt es ja noch niemand bei uns
im Innovationsprojekt.
Und dann war vorbei.
Verhaftet.
Also wahrscheinlich muss ich in Zukunft innovativ sein.
Aber so schlimm ist das gar nicht.
Also ich habe das jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen schlimmer dargestellt,
als es ist.
Ich mache ja so Sachen tatsächlich ganz gerne.
Aber ich wollte vielleicht nicht unbedingt
in der im dritten Monat, wo ich jetzt da bin,
gleich irgendwie zum Superinnovationsprojekt
werden.
Weil was sie mir dann auch erzählt hat,
ist, dazu gehören natürlich auch Präsentationen von Innovationen
vor dem Führungskreis.
Da dachte ich mir auf der einen Seite,
ja gut, da kann man sich irgendwie so ein bisschen so einen Namen
machen und bekannt.
Aber auf der anderen Seite,
da muss man sich auch Mühe geben
und wirklich sich ordentlich darauf vorbereiten,
was man da erzählt.
Auf der anderen Seite,
wenn man sich so ein bisschen vor dem Führungskreis
auf der anderen Seite,
wäre ich jetzt der ultra Hardcore Karriere Grinder,
wäre das natürlich für mich gefunden,
gefundenes Fressen.
Ja, aber ihr wisst,
ich bin nicht der Karriere Grinder.
Innovation wäre ja,
dass ein Linux-Engineer,
ein Linux-Rechner mit ordentlich Rechten bekommt.
Chat, es gibt zwei Sachen.
Max, gute Idee.
Es gibt tatsächlich,
es gibt tatsächlich zwei Sachen,
die ich, die ich einkippen möchte.
Im Innovationsding.
Das habe ich mir schon überlegt.
Und eins davon und eins davon werden Linux-Laptops sein.
Und das andere,
das werden wir demnächst im Stream mal erproben,
dass ich weiß, was ich da überhaupt vorschlage.
Guter G-Bait-Versuch.
Hast du keine Kommentarfilter auf YouTube?
Doch, aber bei mir gibt es wenig Geflame.
Und das war jetzt ja auch nicht so krass.
Ich meine ernsthaft,
das Comment ist mega high IQ versus den YouTube-Durchschnitt.
Der schreibt ja noch halbwegs zusammenhängende logische Sachen,
auch wenn er ein bisschen rumflamet am Ende.
Das ist weit, weit über YouTube-Niveau.
Hast du mittlerweile das Adobe Cloud-Abo für Kubernetes Cluster?
Ist das Sebaro eigentlich?
Karriere Grind Modus aktiviert.
Hey, ohne Mist,
wenn ich das wirklich,
wenn ich das wirklich machen sollte,
ist das natürlich ein Top-Thema,
was ich, wenn es um mehr Geld geht,
meinem Chef auf die Nase binden kann.
Jetzt ernsthaft, ich glaube,
du sprichst aus Erfahrung, was das angeht, oder?
Ich weiß, du meinst nur so semi-ernst,
aber ich glaube, du hast Erfahrung mit sowas, gell?
Also insofern, das ist wahrscheinlich echt so.
Gerade wenn du irgendwelchen BWL-Stonks-Leuten was erzählst,
im Endeffekt musst du denen bestimmt nicht ankommen mit Kubernetes Cluster.
Denen erzählst du dann einfach,
okay, da machen die Leute in der gleichen Zeit das Doppelte,
also Big Stonks.
Und dann sagen die, jawohl!
Max, das machen wir!
Ich nehme ein GIF-Emotes mit zur Präsentation.
Ich habe, ich hatte tatsächlich schon ein paar GIFs in Präsentationen drinnen.
Einmal wurde sich darüber aufgeregt,
aber das war noch bei der alten Arbeit,
dass die Präsentation ja nicht im Corporate-Design wäre
und dass man die so nicht verwenden kann,
weil die nicht im Corporate-Design ist.
Und dann wurde ich gefragt, so,
ja, ob wir die nochmal überarbeiten können
und dann in den Raum posten können,
wenn wir die im Corporate-Design überarbeitet haben.
Also ich habe, das war eine Präsentation,
die habe ich zusammen mit einem Kollege gehalten,
damals übrigens der gleiche Kollege,
der mit mir jetzt auch da bei der neuen Arbeit ist,
haben wir halt gesagt,
ja, das wäre nicht im Corporate-Design
und das könnte man da so nirgendwo reinhängen
und ob wir das nicht nochmal überarbeiten können ins Corporate-Design
und dass ich das dann uploaden können.
Natürlich, was haben wir gemacht?
Wir standen da vorne, haben gesagt,
ja klar, wir gucken uns das nochmal an
und schauen, dass wir die Präsentation ein bisschen anpassen.
Was meint ihr Leute?
Ist das jemals passiert, ja oder nein?
Die Präsentation gibt es bis heute nicht im Corporate-Design.
Ich meine, da stehst halt vorne, was willst du sagen?
Ich kann ja schlecht sagen, nee, kein Bock.
Aber man kann sagen, ja, macht man und macht es dann nie,
weil da denkt eh keiner dran.
Die gibt es bis heute nicht im Corporate-Design.
Sind in euren Unternehmen, ja, bei uns sind GIFs erlaubt,
aber wisst ihr, was bei uns nicht erlaubt ist?
Auch absoluter Keck-W.
Wir dürfen Nachrichten nicht editieren.
Und jetzt kommt der Hammer.
Jetzt kommt der Hammer.
Warum? Also hören sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich stimmt.
Angeblich haben irgendwelche Börsentrading-Leute
mal beschissen über Teams.
Und es gab Probleme.
Und die haben die Teams-Nachrichten gelöscht,
wo sie sich über den Beschiss ausgetauscht haben.
Und seitdem wurde Teams-Editieren gesperrt,
damit nicht mehr beschissen werden kann.
Tja, so kann es gehen, ne?
Ach, den hatten wir auch mal irgendwann.
Wir sind rip-off da,
wir müssen etliche Kunden-Kubernetes updaten
und verlieren die Update.
Ja, dann, sagen wir mal, zack, zack, oder?
Ich meine, der geht ja nicht kaputt dadurch,
dass der alte weiterläuft.
Aber das Upgraden wird schwieriger.
Habe ich noch nie gemacht,
so altes Zeug auf neues Zeug,
wo quasi offiziell keine direkte Upgrade-Möglichkeit
angeboten wird.
Habe ich nie gemacht.
Keine Ahnung, wie man das am besten macht.
Wahrscheinlich muss man den updaten
auf eine Zwischenversion
und dann von der Zwischenversion
auf eine supportete Version oder sowas.
Würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Habe ich nie gemacht.
An diese Fifate-Idee
kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Fifate-Idee.
Das Einzige, was,
wenn ich neue Technologien vorschlage,
diverser wird,
ist der Wildwuchs an unterschiedlichen Technologien.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
Also es gibt, da gibt es bessere Sachen.
Man kann auch sagen,
ich nehme, ich nehme das mit.
Ich nehme das mit,
ich nehme das mit,
ist auch immer so ein 0815-Satz,
wo nie was passieren wird.
Oder alternativ,
Chat, ihr wisst,
was ist denn,
was ist die nächste Steigerung von,
ich nehme das mit?
Was kommt, okay,
also wenn in einem Meeting was drankommt
und ihr sollt euch drum kümmern,
dann sagt, ja, okay,
wir nehmen das mit.
Und wenn,
und wenn das jemals wieder zur Sprache kommt,
was kommt dann?
Was kommt dann?
Wir sind dran, richtig.
Ich sehe,
ich sehe Chat,
ihr wisst Bescheid.
Wir sind dran,
kommt dann.
Ach so,
Moment,
sollte,
wollte ich nicht,
wollte ich nicht eigentlich erklären,
was ich im neuen Job mache,
weil jemand gefragt hat?
Das habe ich nicht gemacht,
oder?
Das habe ich einfach geskippt,
weil ich Askiquarium aufgemacht habe.
Ey, ich glaube,
das, glaube,
das habe ich ganz vergessen.
Also,
was mache ich denn?
Wie fasse ich denn das am besten,
oder was, wie,
was erzähle ich?
Also,
hauptsächlich bin ich aktuell,
also,
man muss dazu sagen,
eingestellt wurde ich als Senior Linux Engineer
mit ziemlich viel Cloud-Fokus.
Da stand eine Stellenanzeige drin
und das ging auch aus meiner Bewerbung hervor,
dass ich,
was heißt Bewerbung?
Im, im,
im Vorstellungsgespräch hervor,
dass ich da Bock drauf habe.
Sagen wir mal so,
Bewerbung im eigentlichen Sinne
mit, oh,
ich bin so super motiviert,
dass ich das mache,
wie gab es ja gar nicht.
So,
und,
dementsprechend,
nachdem meine Position,
quasi auch hauptsächlich,
für,
ja, jemand der Linux kennt
und sich mit Cloud auskennt,
geschaffen wurde,
ich bin aktuell in einem Projekt,
was sich mit,
neuen Technologien beschäftigt.
Im Detail weiß ich nicht,
ob ich das erzählen soll,
weil,
vielleicht kommt ja doch mal
irgendwas Sinnvolles bei raus
und es kommt dann in die News
und dann ist relativ klar,
was das eigentlich sein könnte,
wo ich bin.
Naja,
also,
wir benutzen hauptsächlich
Google Cloud,
ich glaube das ist nicht verboten,
das kann ich schon sagen,
Google Cloud,
aber nicht Google Cloud exklusiv,
alles mögliche,
ich benutze aber aktuell auf der Arbeit
hauptsächlich Google Cloud
und was mache ich?
Ich kümmere mich um unsere
Kubernetes Cluster,
ich kümmere mich um Terraform-Config
zum automatischen Professionieren
von 4Ms,
Kubernetes Cluster,
ich,
mache ein bisschen DevOps-Kram,
wie früher,
auch,
aber ihr kennt mich,
ich bastel und programmiere ja gerne was
für unsere Automatisierungs-Pipelines,
ich letzte Woche beispielsweise
erst eingebaut,
dass man,
jetzt kommt's,
jetzt kommt wieder was,
wo ich eigentlich sagen müsste,
da müsste man jetzt einen Tipp befolgen,
müsste ich meinen eigenen Tipp befolgen
aus dem letzten Video,
und zwar,
Cloud-Infrastruktur
professionieren ja viele Leute
über Terraform,
ja, also zum Beispiel bei AWS
oder Azure
oder so eine 4M zu professionieren,
das machen ja viele Leute
über Terraform,
wer das nicht kennt,
ich zeige das mal kurz,
Terraform,
das ist quasi,
eine Art,
Package Manager ist ein falsches Wort,
wie kann man das vergleichen,
ein Infrastruktur-Professionierer,
SQL für Infrastruktur,
nee, das trifft's auch nicht so ganz,
du kannst damit halt,
in Textform definieren,
was in deiner Cloud-Infrastruktur
aufgebaut werden soll,
du sagst dann beispielsweise nicht mehr,
ich gehe jetzt mal hier bei Google Cloud,
ins UI,
und, achso,
wir sind glaube ich gar nicht mal,
und doch, wir sind noch reingekommen,
Kackel Stream,
tatsächlich,
your free trial is over,
oh nee,
muss ich mir einen neuen Ferkelkraut machen,
ja,
also du musst jetzt nicht zum Beispiel
in die Cloud-Konsole gehen,
und,
dann gehst du auf 4Ms,
gehst du auf 4M erstellen und sowas,
nee, das machst du nicht,
du erstellst das in der Config-Datei,
wirklich schöne Beispiele stehen da nicht,
ja, du definierst das in der Config-Datei,
was deine 4M haben soll,
wie viele CPUs,
wie viele RAM,
welche Disk,
welche Subnetze,
welche Netzwerkgeschichte,
welche IP und sowas,
das definierst du hier in,
in so einer Config-Datei,
und dann,
mach das Terraform für dich,
so, das ist quasi ein Cloud-Provisioning-Tool,
und das ist relativ verbreitet,
dass,
Cloud-Infrastruktur über Terraform provisioniert wird,
ich würd sogar soweit gehen und sagen,
genau, Infrastructure-as-Code,
IAC, nennt sich das,
sagen die coolen Leute dazu,
da ist, da ist Terraform nicht das einzige,
es gibt noch sowas wie,
Pulumi, das ist,
ähnlich zu Terraform, nur etwas,
mehr,
Programmiersprache als so deklarativ,
wie bei Terraform,
wobei Terraform mittlerweile auch,
schon bisschen mehr in Richtung Programmiersprache geht,
mit manchen Sachen,
gut,
zumindest du definierst da, was aufgebaut werden soll,
und Terraform macht das dann für dich,
so, und jetzt haben wir jetzt halt das Ding,
das bei uns auf der Arbeit, wie viele,
provisionieren wir Cloud-Infrastruktur mit Terraform,
das ist tatsächlich das einzige türkische Wort,
was ich kenne, Patrick,
und ich weiß auch, was das heißt,
ähm, also wir provisionieren ja unsere,
unsere Cloud-Infrastruktur mit Terraform,
jetzt gibt's aber das Ding,
dass ganz viele Oldschool-Sachen,
mit Ansible laufen,
so, und jetzt war die Herausforderung,
wie schafft man es denn,
dass man zuerst mit Terraform,
sagen wir mal, eine VM in der Cloud professioniert,
und danach Ansible laufen lässt,
auf dieser VM, um sie ordentlich,
sagen wir mal, unternehmenskonform,
zu,
konfigurieren.
Und das hat bisher noch keiner gemacht,
und ich hab unsere Ansible Automation,
nicht Ansible, unsere, unsere, ähm,
ähm, GitLab-Runner-Pipeline erweitert,
dass man jetzt, nachdem Terraform gelaufen ist,
man Argumente daraus sich ziehen kann,
bisschen, bisschen umformatieren kann,
und an Ansible-Templates übergeben kann,
die dann automatisch über die
AP von dem Ansible-Runner,
quasi Config-Runs auf neu aufgebauten Servers,
Servern triggern.
Also im Endeffekt,
du legst jetzt eigentlich nur noch deine Config an,
sagst hier, ich will eine VM in der Cloud haben,
mit zwei CPUs, mit fünf Gigabyte RAM,
mit 30 Terabyte Festplatte,
und dann legst du noch an,
okay, und danach soll Ansible Playbook
laufen für Aufnahmen ins Monitoring,
Ansible Playbook für Install,
keine Ahnung, Basic-Linux-Sachen,
und Ansible Playbook für Container-Workload.
So, das gibst du an,
und dann professioniert das in der Cloud deine VM,
und lässt danach automatisch die Playbooks laufen.
Das habe ich in unsere Pipeline eingebaut,
dass das funktioniert.
Also solche Sachen mache ich auch noch.
Ansonsten ist es tatsächlich hauptsächlich Kubernetes.
Ziemlich viel rumgebastelt mit einer externen Software,
die wir geliefert bekommen als Helm-Chart,
was einfach nicht funktioniert,
der Dienstleister kriegt es nicht auf die Reihe,
und so Bastel-Kram.
Und halt natürlich noch ab und an
ein bisschen Linux-Support für bestehende Systeme.
Da komme ich tatsächlich ganz gut mit klar bisher.
Klar, ich kenne viele Details
von den bestehenden Systemen nicht,
aber wenn es darum geht,
da läuft irgendwas nicht,
dann sind es ja meistens so die üblichen Sachen
von zu viele Logs,
Festplatte voll, Dienst gecrashed oder sonst was.
Da habe ich mir schon ein paar Sachen angeguckt
mit Leuten, die schon länger da sind zusammen.
Ich habe eigentlich immer rausgekriegt,
der Spur nach,
was es denn jetzt letztendlich gewesen ist.
Da kommt man ganz gut dahinter.
Natürlich, wenn es irgendwas Spezifisches ist,
so nach dem Motto,
mit Support meine ich jetzt,
es gibt irgendwie eine Anwendung,
die crasht und jemand kommt zu uns und sagt,
wir brauchen mal einen,
der sich mit Linux auskennt.
Das ist nicht so,
dass mich jetzt jemand anruft aus dem Außendienst
und sagt, oh Hilfe,
mein Fenster geht nicht richtig auf.
Wenn es natürlich was Spezifisches ist,
wo man wissen muss,
vor 20 Jahren,
was in der Anwendung eingebaut wird,
da habe ich auch gelitten.
Also wie gesagt,
hauptsächlich Kubernetes,
Google Cloud,
Helmcharts basteln
und so ein bisschen DevOps-Kram links und rechts
und Linux-Support für bestehende Systeme.
Ich nenne es mal so Support, ja.
Consulting,
vielleicht der schönere Wort für was auch immer.
Ist auch wurscht, wie man es nennt.
Ich glaube, ihr versteht, was ich meine.
Ja, das ist das,
was ich aktuell auf der Arbeit so mache,
zum größten Teil.
Ja, sehr viel mieten,
natürlich auch.
Also das war jetzt von der technischen Seite.
Es wird sehr viel gemietet.
Also Mietingspensum ist,
ich meine,
Trinken, sehr gute Idee,
Chat, Pfeilpferd.
Mietingspensum ist nicht wirklich weniger,
als auf der alten Arbeit.
Ich habe das zwar im Vorstellungsgespräch
damals sogar angesprochen
und da wurde mir natürlich gesagt,
ja, wir versuchen schon,
die Sachen rechtzeitig zu beenden,
wenn sie denn und so.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
es wird genauso viel gemietet,
auf der alten Arbeit.
Es wird genauso viel gemietet.
Also teilweise übertreiben sie es echt.
Da hast du Tage,
da machst du echt 0, nix,
außer nur mieten.
Letzten Dienstag war auch sowas.
Da habe ich nix gemacht,
außer den ganzen Tag gemietet.
Da war wirklich von morgens bis mittags,
zwischendurch war ich was futtern.
Ansonsten,
konnte sie knicken,
war es einfach den ganzen Tag,
den ganzen Tag gemiete.
Ja, was ist der neue Job?
Also mein offizieller Jobtitel ist
Senior Linux Engineer.
Aber es ist ja dehnbar,
in der IT, was man da macht.
Das ist auch tatsächlich ein Punkt,
den ich mir aufgeschrieben habe.
Wenn ich mal mit meinem Chef
da irgendwann Zwischengespräch,
Probezeit haben sollte.
Es gibt bei uns jetzt schon
die ein oder anderen Sachen,
die man schön verskripten,
automatisieren kann.
Aber eine Sache,
die mir ein bisschen fehlt
aus dem alten Job ist,
ich habe ja auch öfters mal
die ein oder anderen
internen Tools entwickelt.
Sei es jetzt mit .NET was
oder auch mit Go.
Wir haben ja im Stream
sogar schon ein paar Sachen
dafür angefangen.
Das sind so Sachen,
das wäre schön,
wenn sich das mal öfters ergeben würde,
die Gelegenheit dazu.
Und es gibt sicherlich genug,
was man dort automatisieren muss,
beziehungsweise wo man Tools braucht,
um irgendwas einfacher machen zu können.
Hältst du dein Video zur Ausbildung
immer noch für up to date?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
was ich überhaupt erzählt habe.
Streamst du nochmal ein Battle Bit?
Ja, also auf jeden Fall am Wochenende,
weil ich muss noch ein Video dazu machen.
Nee, auch nicht.
Seniors haben jede Menge Meetings.
Ja, das mache ich auch, genau.
Ich sage ja,
man ist heutzutage eher Jaml-Engineer
anstatt was anderes.
Direkt Terraform.
Die haben ja mittlerweile auch so was,
Terraform CDK kannst du dir mal angucken.
Die haben ja mittlerweile auch was,
wo man Terraform ordentlich skripten kann.
Geht's aber los.
Ich habe gerade was getrunken.
Wenn Stackoverflow was dazu schreibt,
ist es nicht gesagt,
dass das bei uns in der Infrastruktur abbildbar ist.
Die einfachste Variante prinzipiell wäre,
du würdest,
ich weiß nicht, wie die das hier machen,
ja, die einfachste Variante
wäre ein Cloud-Init-Job,
der die jeweilige Rolle für den Server abruft.
Aber das geht bei uns nicht so einfach.
Wie viele Leute,
das ist,
das können wir tatsächlich mal wieder um Umfrage machen.
Wir machen mal eine Umfrage,
finde ich ganz gut.
Ich kopiere das,
ich kopiere das einfach.
Wie viele Leute aus dem Chat,
arbeiten im IT-Bereich?
Ja? Nein.
Und ich erlaue keine additional Votes.
Ja, die bald,
die, okay, okay, Moment, Moment.
Kann ich, kann ich, kann ich die Abstimmung abbrechen?
Wartet mal.
Ne.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man,
kann man das beenden?
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Sonst erzähle ich, erzähle ich bald, bald.
Ich kann meine eigenen Umfragen nicht mehr abbrechen.
Okay, die meisten Leute,
das habe ich mir auch gedacht,
dass viele hier sind.
Viele Hackermans.
Was soll ich anklicken,
wenn ich im September anfange?
Nein.
Na ja, klick an, was du willst.
Wenn du dich schon so als ITler fühlst,
klick ja an.
Also ich denke,
wenn ihr, wenn ihr,
wenn ihr IT studiert oder sowas,
wir machen,
ich mache die Umfrage nochmal.
Wir machen, wir machen das gerade nochmal.
Also jetzt sind wir bei 78 Prozent.
Wir machen das gerade nochmal.
Komm her.
Arbeiten im IT-Bereich.
Ja?
Bald?
Nein.
Und Leute, die studieren und sowas,
die oder Ausbildung machen,
oder gut, Ausbildung würde ich ja schon sagen,
und die studieren oder es vorhaben,
oder können ja, können ja bald,
bald auswählen, ja.
So, machen wir das Ganze nochmal.
Würdest du jemand ohne Ausbildung
Studium einstellen?
Das kommt auf die Bewerbung an.
Wenn er sich bewirbt mit,
ich war vorher Metzgerei-Fachverkäufer,
habe keine Ahnung von Computern
und habe nie was gemacht in dem Bereich,
dann eher nicht.
Okay, also sprich,
70 Prozent arbeiten in der IT,
16 Prozent sind entweder
am Studio zu studieren
oder haben vor,
bald dort zu arbeiten,
haben vielleicht schon eine Stelle,
die noch nicht losgegangen ist.
Und ansonsten, nein.
Gibt auch welche, die gucken so zu.
Was ich auch sehr nice finde, Leute.
Hog für alle, die einfach nur so zugucken.
Und bei der Gelegenheit
kann ich natürlich nur noch mal erwähnen,
lasst eure Prime Subs nicht verfallen, Schätzchen.
Ich weiß jetzt noch,
bis die Abstimmung durch ist,
aber ich denke, das Ergebnis
wird mehr oder weniger gleich bleiben.
Duales berufsbegleitendes Studium
at IBM.
Ach so, duale, okay, bei IBM.
I am Phonex.
Dankeschön, huge subscription.
69.
Okay, interessant,
aber ich dachte es mir,
ehrlich gesagt, schon,
dass das ungefähr so ausfällt.
Der Herrscher,
fünf Monate,
danke schön für den Sub.
Chanka not Chunk.
Danke für den Sub.
Chimbo, Chimchu,
Timchu, auch am Start.
Alter, mega Subscription hier, Alter.
Für die ganzen Weebs unter uns,
jetzt noch mal eine Runde.
Jetzt aber genug hier.
Jetzt wieder, jetzt wieder out.
Zentrix,
Eieiei,
vier gifte Subs.
Dankeschön, Zentrix.
Ich komme, ich komme gleich dazu.
Ich erkenne die Namen
nicht richtig im Chat,
aber bestimmt wieder,
bestimmt wieder erfolgreich
dodge die meisten Leute.
Oh, ein Cheesy Cake.
Zitrix, liest sich so ähnlich,
wobei, wobei, wobei Zitrix,
glaube ich,
ich glaube, Zitrix,
ja auch eher Shedrix gesprochen wird.
Immer was trinken,
das ist richtig.
Wir haben deswegen sogar
Channel Points dafür.
Was?
Schau mal bei,
bei deinem Fan,
ob du Gönnerji bekommst.
Was?
Was zum Teufel ist Gönnerji?
Und wird er nicht,
wird er nicht von Monster Energy
gesponsert?
Oder ist das schon wieder
outdated, overrated,
jebaited?
Okay, er hat einen eigenen
Energy Drink.
Gut, sie meinen so viele
Energy Drinks,
wie das säuft.
Bietet sich das ja auch
irgendwie an.
Außerdem kann man damit
Big Stonks machen.
Also nachvollziehbar.
Und wie viel pimmelst du rum?
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht
ganz sicher,
auf was sich die Frage
genau bezieht.
Ich vermute,
es ging da drum,
was ich auf der Arbeit mache
und wie viel ich arbeite
und wie viel ich nur rumpimmele.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Please clarify,
was genau gemeint ist.
Das habe ich richtig
interpretiert.
Okay,
ja,
also,
nachdem der Meetinganteil
relativ hoch ist,
würde ich sagen,
pimmel ich bestimmt
50% der Zeit rum,
weil es Meetings sind.
Aber das sind von der Firma
verordnete und vorgeschriebene
Meetings.
Kann ich auch nichts für.
Ich weiß nicht,
ich versuche wenigstens
bei den Meetings
aktiv was zu sagen
oder mich einzubringen.
Außer es ist ganz so lang,
ganz zu,
ich will nicht sagen,
dass ich das bei jedem
Meeting mache, ja?
Das wäre jetzt gelogen.
Manche sind auch
ultra langweilig
und ich schalte geistig
irgendwie schon ab
nach fünf Minuten.
Aber bei den,
bei denen,
wo es irgendwann um was geht,
was mich betrifft,
dann versuche ich wenigstens
was mich einzubringen.
Es ist aber auch manchmal
nicht allzu clever,
sich einzubringen,
wie man heute Morgen gesehen hat,
weil bald muss ich
innovative Sachen machen,
höchstwahrscheinlich.
Aber eigentlich ist es nicht schlimm.
Ich glaube,
das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Halbe Schnitt,
zwei bis drei Meetings pro Tag.
Okay, Leute,
haltet euch mal fest.
Ich lese euch jetzt mal vor,
Dienstag,
passt mal auf.
Ich glaube,
Dienstag kann ich gut vorlesen,
weil dort sind die Meetings
vom Namen her nicht so,
nicht so spezifisch,
dass ich jetzt irgendwas verraten würde.
Okay, also Dienstag.
Okay, passt auf.
Okay, ich lasse mal,
ich lasse mal die
die Vor-Ort-Veranstaltung weg.
Die war ja nur außer,
außer, außer,
außer dem Rahmen, ja.
Also es geht los.
9.30 Uhr, Daily Scrum.
Wir sind furchtbar agile.
So, also 9.30 Uhr, Daily Scrum.
Dann parallel 9.30 Uhr,
Sprint Review von,
von was anderem.
Also ich, ich,
ich scrumme und sprinte gleichzeitig.
Dann 11 Uhr, Sprint Retrospektive Teil 1.
Zwischendurch noch ein Termin,
ja, Connection Test,
das war was anderes.
Dann weiter,
Sprint, Sprint Retrospektive,
also das,
jetzt sind wir schon,
jetzt sind wir schon bei 14,
bei 14.15 Uhr.
Sprint Retrospektive Part 2.
14.30 Uhr, Sprint Planung.
16.30 Uhr,
weiteres Connection Test Meeting,
aber 16.30 Uhr war ich schon weg.
Da war, da habe ich gerade
im Zug gesessen,
gesessen auf dem Heimweg
und war nur noch
mit dem Kopfhörer drinne.
Also, jetzt ratet mal,
wie viel ich am Dienstag
wirklich gemacht habe.
Gehen die Meetings ineinander über?
Ja, mehr oder weniger,
aber sind trotzdem,
trotzdem Bürowechsel zwischendurch dabei.
Nix, richtig.
Ich habe am Dienstag
wirklich nichts gemacht,
gar nichts.
Ich konnte nichts machen.
Es war quasi ab dem Zeitpunkt,
wo ich aufgeschlagen bin,
dort bis zu wo ich weg bin,
Dauermeeting.
Kennt ihr eigentlich
einen guten YAML Editor?
Was hast du gegen Visual Studio Code?
Vim, Vim geht immer, Emacs.
Aber ich meine,
was spricht gegen Visual Studio Code?
Das ist so eigentlich
ja nur nach 15 Editor.
Du kannst alles vernehmen,
alles nehmen.
Du hast bestimmt irgendeine
Idee für dein Kram
oder kannst es auch reinschmeißen.
YAML, Syntax, Highlighting
und Formatting
hat das Ding bestimmt auch.
Weil YAML Formatting
so ein Ding ist,
das kann auf Mist formatieren.
Oh, da wäre ich,
First Level Support
würde ich nicht lange machen.
Meeting Selfie unangekündigt.
Ja, sowas sollte
auch nicht die Regel sein.
Also wenn einer was einlädt
und es dann nicht stattfindet,
sollte es gefälligst abgesagt werden.
Kannst du Linux als dein Haupt-US
auf der Arbeit nutzen?
Ja und nein,
je nachdem wie man es nimmt.
Also so gut,
wie es auf der alten Arbeit war,
ist es nicht,
weil auf der alten Arbeit
hatte ich einen Laptop,
der war komplett mit Linux
und ich hatte noch
einen zweiten Laptop mit Windows.
Jetzt habe ich einen Laptop
zu geflastert,
mit allen möglichen
Security-Tools,
Windows,
aber eine Admin-VM,
auf der ich Root bin
und ich habe auf meinem Windows-Laptop
zum größten Teil
eigentlich nur Terminal
im Fullscreen auf.
Das ist übrigens auch eine Sache,
die ich gerne mal
beim Thema Innovation
dann einbringen würde.
Wie wäre es denn mit Deluxe Clients?
Was hältst du von Obsidian?
Ich habe es nie großartig ausprobiert,
weil es ein Feature nicht hat,
was ich gerne hätte.
Nämlich Notifications
auf Mobile-Geräten.
Zum Beispiel,
wenn man dort einen Termin einträgt
oder irgendeinen Due Date,
Due Date,
wie auch immer man da spricht,
Fälligkeitsdatum auf Deutsch,
dass man dann eine Nachricht kriegt
und das kann die Mobile-Variante nicht.
Weiß nicht,
vielleicht kann sie das mittlerweile,
aber ich glaube nicht.
Ja, Android-Devices,
bla bla bla.
Ne, das geht immer noch nicht.
Was hältst du von Mobile X-Term
auf Windows?
Viel Abstand.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit
auch viele Leute,
die Mobile X-Term verwenden,
in der Mangelung
irgendwie bessere Alternativen.
Aber ich habe Visual Studio Code
und benutze das Visual Studio Code Terminal.
Ansonsten,
ja, es gibt jede Menge
gute Alternativen,
aber die musst du halt erst mal
in die Software-Verteilung
bei deiner Firma kriegen,
je nachdem wie restriktiv die sind.
Also die einfachste Alternative
ist tatsächlich das Windows-Terminal
in Kombination mit WSL und WSLG.
Das ist eigentlich,
wenn es Windows-only sein soll,
nicht verkehrt.
Es gibt noch West Term,
das würde ich persönlich sogar vorziehen,
weil ich dann meine Konfig
von Linux verwenden könnte.
Aber das neue Windows-Terminal,
das neue Microsoft-Terminal
in Kombination mit WSL und WSLG
ist schon ganz gut.
Das kommt einem Linux noch am nächsten,
wenn es rein Windows sein soll.
Windows 10 oder 11
macht keinen Unterschied, geht beides.
WSLG ist ein X-Server für,
ich glaube streng genommen
ist es kein X-Server.
Du kannst grafische Linux-Programme
unter Windows auch anzeigen damit.
Das ist glaube ich streng genommen
kein X-Server,
sondern irgendwas anderes.
Es kann auch Wayland-Programme
und es kann X-Programme
und alles mögliche.
Ich weiß nicht,
als wie man es korrekt klassifiziert.
Vor allem Workstation Pro
versus VirtualBox.
Ich mag vor allem Workstation.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich hatte keinen Bock mehr auf VirtualBox.
Mir ist vor allem Workstation lieber.
Und die Keys sind auch nicht teuer,
wenn du die bei irgendeinem Shop kaufst.
Also mir fällt jetzt nichts ein
unter dieser Bezeichnung.
Aber ich weiß, was du meinst.
Und ich gehe davon aus,
vermutlich, dass wir das noch haben.
Habe ich aber nichts mit zu tun.
Nope, ich kenne das,
aber ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Nixo, es ist doch das,
wo alles kontainerisiert läuft, oder?
Oder war das was anderes?
Chetke?
Ach nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist das mit diesem
komischen Package Manager,
der auch irgendwie
alle Dependencies
immer mit installiert und sowas.
Ja, das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Zählt ab und zu Netzwerkleitung
auf und patcht als IT-Shop?
Ja, schon, im IT-Umfeld auf jeden Fall.
Ich meine, wenn du Leitungen patchst,
dann ist das ja bestimmt
nicht das Einzige, was du machst.
Da hast du bestimmt auch
ein bisschen was mit
Netzwerk-Hardware zu tun.
Oder geht es dir quasi
um Gebäudeverkabelung?
So nach dem Motto,
ich mache eigentlich mit Hardware
und Technik gar nichts.
Ich lege halt ab und zu mal eine Leitung.
Ja, nee, dann würde ich nicht sagen,
dass es als IT-Shop durchgeht.
Wie lange seid ihr schon
in der IT dabei?
Also ich seit über 15 Jahren.
Wollen wir auch mal
eine Umfrage machen, Leute?
Wie lange sind wir schon in der IT?
Komm, machen wir.
Ich mache mal eine Umfrage.
Wie lange arbeitet ihr schon
in der IT?
Was machen wir denn da?
Eins bis drei Jahre?
Was ist denn da ein guter
mit oder ohne Ausbildungszeit?
Mit, mit, mit.
Man sagt zwar immer,
es zählt nicht,
es zählt nicht dazu,
aber ehrlich gesagt,
es ist ja trotzdem Arbeiten in der IT.
Okay, Motke weiß Bescheid.
Zwei bis fünf, fünf bis zehn,
zehn plus.
Das müssen wir so machen.
Mehr kann man eh nicht eintragen.
Okay, wir machen noch zehn bis 15
und dann 15 plus.
Okay, Start.
20 plus ist 15 plus.
Inklusive Ausbildung.
Ausbildung kann ich mitrechnen.
Das konntest du
vorher schon abstimmen
in der letzten Umfrage.
Also bei mir ist
bei mir sind es jetzt 16 Jahre.
Du hast die Intervalle verkackt.
Das stimmt, die überlappen sich.
Egal.
So für ein grobes Bild
reicht es, glaube ich.
Alles dabei hier.
Kein Wunder,
dass das Stream so high IQ ist.
Einfach enormst a big brain.
Ja, guckt.
Nice Distribution.
Also habe ich ja
vorhin schon darauf geantwortet.
Kommt darauf an,
was in der Bewerbung steht.
Also ich würde es nicht
prinzipiell ausschließen,
aber es kommt halt ganz darauf an.
Chaotix schreibt,
hatte neulich mal
eine Stellenausschreibung.
Ich glaube, ich erinnere mich.
Hatten neulich mal
eine Stellenausschreibung
angesehen von mir.
Du hattest ein paar Fragen
beziehungsweise Anregungen
dazu gegeben
und das hat mir gut geholfen.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe die Stelle sehr nice.
Das ist extremly.
Wann geht's los?
Wahrscheinlich im September oder so.
Oder oder oder August schon.
Oder jetzt gleich.
1.9.
Bock.
Okay, Ed Wobloz
folgende Anwendungsfall.
Ich will unsere Cisco Switches.
Initial Konfig automatisieren.
Hatte mit Netzwerk Hardware.
Darfst du mich nicht fragen?
Hatte mir Ansible rausgesucht.
Wie würdest du das machen?
Hatte an einen Linux-Server
mit Ansible Playbook
und jedes Mal Inventory-File
für das Gerät anpassen.
Geht nur um Initial Konfig.
Meine ganz blöde Idee.
Ich finde, ich finde es ja immer gut,
die Sachen möglichst simpel zu halten.
Du kannst das sicherlich
mit Ansible oder so was bauen.
Aber wenn es dir nur um
um initiale Standard Konfig geht,
wovon ich jetzt einfach mal ausgehe,
weil was anderes
wird es ja mit Ansible auch nicht machen.
Du musst das Ding doch am Anfang
eh flashen und Firmware updaten, oder?
Warum nicht in diesem Zuge
einfach gleich eine Konfig mit drauf?
Wäre das nicht einfacher
als irgendwelche Ansible-Sachen zu machen?
Irgendwelche Konfig draufhauen.
Gut ist.
Du musst ja eh drauf Konfig update.
Also Firmware update machen.
Und ansonsten ja,
so was kann man sicherlich
mit Ansible machen.
Ich gehe stark von aus,
dass es für Ansible Provider gibt
für Cisco Switch Konfig und so was.
Ich meine, es gibt ja sogar
für MikroTik Ansible, ja?
Ansible MikroTik.
Also gibt es garantiert auch so was
für für Cisco.
Und ich meine,
das ist ja auch nicht so einfach.
Das ist ja auch nicht so einfach.
Für Cisco.
Was ich kenne von Cisco ist.
So heißt das, glaube ich.
Das ist auch irgendwelche.
Ich glaube, das ist auch irgendwas,
was was was mit Konfigmanagement
für Cisco Switch zu tun hat.
Aber das hat unser Netzwerk
Team beim alten Arbeitgeber
immer verwendet.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob das was taugt.
Aber ansonsten klingt das doch
mit Ansible eigentlich gar.
Also gerade wenn es
ein bisschen dynamisch sein muss.
Oder so ein bisschen Templaten muss,
sagen wir mal in Ansible.
Ja, kann man machen.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt
vielleicht sogar.
Ach so, du brauchst
übrigens kein Playbook.
Du kannst auch direkt Ansible
gegen eine IP ausführen.
Also brauchst du kein Playbook
erstellen dafür.
Die Sonntags ist ein bisschen
ein bisschen eklig,
aber das geht.
Also du brauchst kein Inventory.
Playbook schon.
Du brauchst kein Inventory
erstellen so viel.
Du kannst auch direkt
ein Host angeben als Inventory
auf der Command Line.
Ja, direkt gegen eine IP.
Das funktioniert so.
Warte mal Ansible.
Ach Shit, das hatten wir
auf der alten 4M.
Fields Batman.
Habe ich die hier noch?
Broggers, jawohl.
Kommen wir doch gerade mal.
Das ist gar nicht so,
gar nicht so schwierig.
Die Sonntags,
die Sonntags ist bloß abartig.
Warte mal.
Ja.
Ja, das ist aber auch
ja Ansible.
Ja.
Du musst es so schreiben.
Guck Ansible Playbook minus I
und du musst hier an der Stelle
ein Komma machen,
sonst passt es das nicht richtig.
Vielleicht war das auch
damals ein Bug.
Weiß ich nicht.
Also es hat es hat so.
So hat es nicht funktioniert.
So funktioniert es aber.
Vielleicht ist es auch
einfach nur Inventory Syntax.
So kannst du das gegen
eine einzelne Kiste laufen lassen.
Aber es klingt klingt sinnig,
das mit Ansible zu machen.
Auf jeden Fall noch
in irgendeinem Git Repo einchecken.
Wo es ja nicht öffentlich auf Git
habt, eure Passwörter posten
sowas, aber ich würde
auf jeden Fall ein Git Repo machen.
Dass man nachvollziehen kann,
was sich wie geändert hat.
Und wenn ihr mal
was ausprobieren wollt,
könnt ihr das auch
einem extra Branch machen.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Du kannst das Limit Flag setzen.
Das bringt dir aber nichts,
weil du den Switch
nicht im Inventory drin hast.
Limit bringt ja nur was,
wenn du ein Inventory hast.
Du willst es limitieren
auf Sachen aus dem Inventory.
Er hat ja gar kein Inventory.
Oder wie mal ein
englischer Kollege
früher gesagt hat,
bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Ich weiß nicht,
wo der aus England kam.
Der hatte hatte
so ein Dialekt.
Der hat nicht Inventory gesagt.
Der hat immer gesagt Inventory.
Inventory.
Also scheinen sich da
auch nicht so ganz einig zu sein.
Das ist hier schon wieder
Max Consulting am Start gewesen.
Wonex oder Fonex.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
POG Subscription.
Nein.
Ich sehe dein Comment nicht.
Ach so.
Habe auf YouTube, glaube ich,
keinen länger abonniert als ich.
Ja, das kann ich sehen.
Wie heißt nur auf YouTube?
Soll ich mal nachgucken?
Komm, wir machen das jetzt.
Heißt du da auch Medo?
Ich habe zwei Leute,
die Medo im Namen haben.
Ich weiß nicht,
welcher davon du bist,
falls du einer davon bist.
Welcher Medo bist du?
Oh, bin ich 20 Minuten
hintendran mit dem Chat?
Alter, ich kacke nur.
Alter, wie lahm bin ich
denn wieder hier hintendran?
Ich muss jetzt wieder aufhören.
Drunken Mayer,
Six Illusional,
Geologist und ein weißer Bär
hat ein Sub gegiftet,
gekriegt vom Zentrix.
Exzellent Subscriptions.
Das ist eine Playlist
Top 100 Mario Songs.
Das ist Yoshi Island.
Ja, Zelbaron
müsste auch mal wieder vorbeikommen.
Ja, habe ich gehört.
Das ist ja aktuell so ein bisschen
so ein bisschen Hype-Wort,
genauso wie Side Reliability.
Das kann ich nicht aussprechen, Leute.
Genauso wie Side Reliability.
Alter.
Meine Güte.
Höchst kompliziertes Wort.
Gagweight.
Sehr Buzzword mäßig
am Start aktuell.
Kommt bei euren Meetings
was rum oder nur Bullshit?
Teils, teils.
Es ist eigentlich überall.
Manche Sachen sind
gut gewesen,
dass man sie gemacht hat.
Und manche sind nur heiße Luft.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob ich das richtig sagen kann.
Aber es ist eigentlich überall.
Manche Sachen sind
gut gewesen,
dass man sie gemacht hat.
Und manche sind nur heiße Luft.
Ich habe beide hier.
Ich habe mein kabelloses Headset
und das
und mein MMX 300.
Wo es die Leute immer drüber lustig machen
über mein MMX 300, weil
ich habe da doch vorne
so einen Schwamm drauf.
Und die Leute,
die mich zum ersten Mal sehen
in irgendeinem Meeting.
Also ja, ich habe manchmal
eine Webcam an auf der Arbeit.
Ich will nicht wissen,
wie oft ich den Kartoffelwitz
schon gehört habe.
Ich habe ja für meinen MMX 300
einen Popschutz gebaut
aus dem WC.
Aus einem gelben Schwamm,
so einem Schwamm,
den man für Auto,
fürs Autowäschen
normalerweise benutzt.
Weil es, weil es
ein viel besserer Popschutz ist,
als die ganzen Überzugdinger,
die es für Mikrofone gibt.
Und jedes Mal,
wenn irgendjemand mich neu sieht
in einem Meeting,
kommt dann so Dinge wie
Max, warum hast du
eine Kartoffel im Gesicht?
Ha ha ha, lulululul.
Und da finden sie sich
immer furchtbar innovativ
und originell.
Dabei habe ich das schon
tausendmal gehört
mittlerweile diesen Sprachen.
Wie lange dauern eure Meetings
im Durchschnitt?
Kann ich nicht sagen.
Puh, boah, kann doch.
Im Durchschnitt 45 Minuten.
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Aber, aber, sagen wir mal so,
wir haben auch bürokratische Dinger.
Ich glaube, es ist recht verbreitet,
dass es, dass es oftmals
an manchen Tagen mit Meetings
übertrieben wird.
Ja, das nervt mich auch immer.
Also ich muss sagen,
eine Sache hat mir geholfen.
Jetzt nicht beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber,
sondern beim alten schon.
Das ist Blocker,
Blocker Termine einzutragen.
Einfach, dass man
keine einladen kann in der Zeit,
ohne die Nachricht zu bekommen,
dass man nicht verfügbar ist.
Also das ist,
das ist so eins der Dinger.
Ja, und Termine abzusagen.
Beziehungsweise dort Bescheid zu sagen,
dass man, dass sie zu spät sind.
Weil es gibt bei uns auch Meetings,
teilweise die sind eingetragen,
irgendwie 15 bis 17 Uhr 30 und sowas.
Da denke ich mir mal, Alter,
wer ist dann so lange am Start?
Und das haben sie mittlerweile
auch schon gelernt.
Also das mit dem Blocker eintragen
hat mir gerade
beim alten Arbeitgeber geholfen.
Ich habe nämlich jeden Tag eingetragen,
ab 15.30 Uhr,
da ich keine Zeit mehr habe.
15.30 Uhr habe ich eingetragen,
bis quasi 7 Uhr morgens.
Nächsten Tag.
Da konnte, konnte mich
keiner mehr einladen,
weil, wie gesagt,
ich will ja dann spätestens 16 Uhr,
wollte ich abhauen.
Und ich haue auch 16 Uhr ab.
Ich bin so früh da,
ich komme im Zweifelsfall
sonst irgendwann mal
über 10 Stunden oder so.
Das muss ja nicht sein.
Und ich haue da noch ab.
Also ich sage das auch mittlerweile,
sage ich, Jungs,
also ist das eigentlich zu spät?
Ich kann am Anfang teilnehmen
und ich kann auch noch auf dem Heimweg
hier per Teams,
zum Headset dabei bleiben.
Aber 16 Uhr muss ich zum Hauptbahnhof,
sonst wird es zu spät.
Hat sich bis jetzt auch noch
keiner beschwert?
Ich denke auch,
gibt es nichts,
wo man sich beschweren kann?
Ich meine, die Uhr,
wer Meetings bis 17 Uhr macht,
das ist auch irgendwie lost.
Hast du noch Kontakt
zu den Leuten früher?
Ja, teilweise schon.
Witzigerweise hat mich die Cynthia beraten,
als ich mir ein Auto kaufen wollte.
Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht,
dass er mal so wieder Kontakt
mit den Leuten von früher hat.
Die hat mir, hat mir erklärt,
wie das bei Fiat so läuft.
Weil die wohl Arbeit,
die Arbeit wohl für,
für irgendeinen Dienstleister
da in der Ecke.
Vielleicht habe ich deswegen auch
das so günstig gekriegt.
Weiß ich nicht.
Kann schon durchaus sein.
So, Leute, wir müssen
jetzt mal zum Ende kommen.
Bolgi19, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Vier Monate Hyper-Subscription hier.
Der Discord hat dich
durch die Ausbildung gebracht.
Da bist du schon lange am Start.
Ja, der Discord ist teilweise
sehr feinfett, genauso wie der Chat.
Manche Leute
gehen mir aber auf den Sack.
Da lese ich teilweise
schon gar nicht mehr,
wenn da wieder irgendwie
im Kreis diskutiert wird.
Aber letztendlich ist ja,
ich will da auch niemanden bannen
oder löschen oder sonst was,
weil letztendlich ist Discord
ja zum Diskutieren da.
Das heißt ja nicht zwangsläufig,
nur weil ich keinen Bock drauf,
das mir zu Gemüte zu führen,
dass ich da nicht Leute
dran beteiligen wollen.
Machen ja genug.
Nee, nee, nee, lass, lass,
nix löschen.
Ich weiß, du machst das
auch im Zweifelsfall.
Nee, nee.
Kann man i3 WFM aus WSLG
laufen lassen?
Nein, kannst du nicht.
Du kannst keine Desktops starten.
Du kannst nur einzelne
Programme starten.
Was ist, was ist an VMA
besser als Virtualbox?
Ist nicht von Oracle.
In Rancher läuft alles
kontainerisiert.
Na gut, in Rancher,
Rancher ist ja quasi,
ich will jetzt nichts Falsches
sagen, weil ich Rancher so
ganz lange nichts
damit zu tun hatte.
Ich glaube, Rancher ist auch nur
ein Kubernetes Distro
mit ein bisschen GUI.
Mittlerweile.
Die hatten ja mal
ihr eigenes
Container OS.
Ich glaube, das nannte sich,
war das Flat Car?
Oder bringe ich das
jetzt durcheinander?
Oder wie hieß der Vorgänger
davon? Ach, keine Ahnung.
Schon so lange her alles.
Außerdem ist es jetzt
irrelevant.
Suse will demnächst den
Nachfolger von
Suse Enterprise Linus raus.
Oh Gott, Lino,
oh, Suse, Alter, hör mal auf.
Auf der anderen Seite,
ich meine, nachdem Red Hat
sich ja so ein bisschen
in die Scheiße gesetzt hat,
gerade vielleicht,
vielleicht bringt das
ein bisschen was bei Suse.
Wenn ihr mich fragt, Leute.
Einfach Debian benutzen,
sich nicht die ganzen Mist geben.
Oder meinetwegen Ubuntu,
wenn Support braucht.
Aber Red Hat fuckt ab
und Suse sicherlich auch.
Hast du eine Meinung
zu Puppet versus Ansible?
Finde so Agent basierte Tools
immer schwierig,
zum Beispiel in der Summary.
Ich nicht so richtig.
Ich kenne beides.
Ich kann dir aber
eine Sache sagen,
die ich an Puppet
viel besser finde
als an Ansible.
Man hört es immer nur umgedreht.
Man hört immer nur Ansible
ist viel neuer,
einfacher, besser
und eigentlich das Tool der Wahl.
Ja, ist so.
Aber es gibt trotzdem
eine Sache, die finde ich
an Puppet viel besser.
Und zwar Puppet kannst du sagen.
Ich glaube,
wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe,
ist der richtige Befehl dafür
Puppet Agent minus,
minus Test, minus, minus Noob
minus, minus Test hat
übrigens nichts mit Testen zu tun.
Das ist einfach
eine bescheuerte Abkürzung.
So und der tut dann so,
als würde er das Ganze
laufen lassen.
Quasi so einen so einen Try Run
und zeigt dir genau,
was er machen würde.
Das gibt es in dieser Form
in Ansible nicht.
Was es in Ansible gibt,
ist die theoretischen Möglichkeiten,
ein Try Run zu machen.
Das müssen die Module
aber explizit unterstützen.
Also du musst du,
du musst quasi,
du musst das einbauen,
dass das funktioniert.
Und selbst dann weißt du nicht,
ob es, ob er
das dann auch wirklich
so machen würde.
Also in Puppet führt er
die Sachen ja auch aus,
außer, also er führt die,
das ist Blödsinn,
er führt die Sachen nicht aus.
Das ist falsch.
Der erstellt den gesamten Ablauf,
was er ausführen würde.
Und du kannst es genau angucken.
Halt auch,
der templated auch und alles.
Also das ist eine Sache,
die finde ich persönlich
in Puppet viel, viel nicer
als in Ansible,
dass du einen Noob
beziehungsweise einen Try,
einen richtig ordentlichen
Try Run machen kannst.
Das finde ich in Terraform
übrigens auch nice,
dass du,
dass du einen Plan machen kannst
und erst mal gucken.
Ja, ich verstehe nicht,
warum es Tools gibt,
die das nicht richtig können.
Also das ist ein Punkt,
den ich tatsächlich
viel nicer finde an Puppet
als in Ansible.
Insgesamt würde ich sagen,
Ansible ist aber trotzdem
das Tool, was man
in der heutigen Zeit,
wenn man sowas,
wenn man sowas braucht,
höchstwahrscheinlich
eher benutzen will als Puppet.
Was sagst du von Jenkins?
Ich mag Jenkins.
Ich mag auch Nagios.
Heißt nicht unbedingt,
dass ich einen neuen Nagios
betreiben möchte
oder einen neuen Jenkins,
aber ich finde beides ganz nice.
Nagios hat bei mir aber immer,
wobei, ganz ehrlich,
einen neuen Nagios
würde ich nicht,
würde ich nicht mehr betreiben,
weil der neue Nagios
wahrscheinlich nichts
mehr mit dem Nagios zu tun hat,
den ich noch kenne von früher,
weil ich habe mich
in meiner Ausbildung
viel mit Nagios beschäftigt
und ich mochte Nagios eigentlich.
Auch die Config-Files und so.
Ich fand das nie so schlimm,
wie es immer gemacht,
wie es immer geredet wurde.
Heute würde ich das
nicht unbedingt mehr
als neue Monitoring-Lösung
implementieren,
sowas von Nagios,
aber wenn es noch da wäre,
ich hätte da keine Schmerzen mit,
was dran zu machen.
Also ich,
ich mag beides.
Sowohl Jenkins,
als auch Nagios.
In einem Vault
kannst du das speichern.
In einem Ansible Vault.
Ansible Vault.
Ja, kannst du.
Kannst du durchlesen,
was sie da zu schreiben, ja.
Ja, siehste?
Haben wir schon geschrieben.
Kannst du mir mal erklären,
wie Repositories
unter Linux funktionieren?
Kann man das damit vergleichen,
wenn man eine gepackte Datei
unter Windows runterlädt?
Ja.
Im Prinzip schon.
Es hängt ein bisschen davon ab,
was du benutzt.
Es gibt, es gibt,
sagen wir mal so,
vier, fünf größere Package-Manager,
so je nach Distribution.
Was hast du denn?
Du hast YUM,
also das RPM,
du hast Debian,
du hast Arch, by the way,
Pac-Man,
also PKG,
du hast APK
und, was habe ich noch vergessen?
Hab ich was vergessen?
Chat-Gear?
Fifat-Chat?
Ja, Snaps und Flatpacks
zähle ich da jetzt nicht dabei.
Nee, ich glaube, das war's.
War's so halbwegs.
Ja, das kannst du tatsächlich,
DNF ist RPM,
das ist YUM quasi.
Ja, das kannst du tatsächlich
damit vergleichen.
Unter der Haube
macht ein Package-Manager
auch nichts anderes,
wie, sagen wir mal,
Zips runterladen.
Mit dem Unterschied,
dass es ein paar
kleine, feine Unterschiede gibt,
zwischen,
du gehst jetzt bei Google,
suchst dir ein Package,
lädst das runter
und installierst das.
Also,
es gehört noch ein bisschen mehr dazu,
es ist spät,
aber ich versuch's trotzdem
mal kurz zu erklären,
was der Unterschied ist.
Also, als erstens
lädst du's nicht von irgendwelchen
random Seiten runter,
sondern von offiziellen
Paketquellen.
Das ist schon mal ein Unterschied.
Dann hast du Checksummen,
die das Projekt rausgibt,
das heißt, du weißt,
dass das, was runtergeladen wurde,
auch wirklich das Freigegebene ist,
dass dir nicht irgendwelche
China-Chinesen-Seiten
rvlc unterschrieben
mit einem Virus drinne.
Das ist auch ein Vorteil
und
eigentlich der größte Vorteil,
dass Packages
nicht einfach nur Zips sind,
wo die Programme drin sind,
sondern es sind Zips,
wo die Programme drin sind
und
Install-Scripts,
Update-Scripts
und
Cleanup-Scripts.
Das heißt, der Package-Manager
kann
nicht nur die Software installieren
und vielleicht
Default-Config-Dateien anlegen
und sowas,
der kann die Software auch
ordentlich upgraden
oder auch wieder ordentlich löschen,
wenn die Scripts was taugen.
Aber wenn du aus offiziellen
Paketquellen was installierst,
taugt das.
Also zum Beispiel,
wenn du sagst,
du installierst Docker
über einen Paket-Manager,
dann ist es nicht nur so,
dass der dir Docker nach User-Bin,
nee, oder
wo liegt denn Docker?
Bin wahrscheinlich,
ja, dass der dir das
Docker-Binary
irgendwo hinschiebt,
nein,
der installiert dir einen Service,
dass Docker im Hintergrund läuft,
der installiert dir eine,
also der legt dir eine Gruppe an,
in einem Post-Install-Script
eine Gruppe an
für den Docker-User,
der legt die nötigen Verzeichnisse an,
der legt die Hilfe-Dateien an,
dass du dir die Hilfe-Seiten
von Docker angucken kannst,
der gibt den Dateien
die richtige Berechtigung,
dass sie ausführbar sind
und solche Post-Install-Scripts
lässt ein Package-Manager auch laufen,
das ist das,
was unter Windows quasi
auch ein Installer machen würde,
im Gegensatz zu einem einfachen Zip.
Nur, dass du dich halt
nicht selbst drum kümmern musst
und ein Paket-Manager auch
zentral alle Pakete updaten kann.
Also ja, man kann schon sagen,
dass da auch nur Zips runtergeladen werden,
aber in diesen Zips ist noch mehr drin
als die Software selbst.
Das ist wie bei vielen Buzzwords,
jeder macht da ein bisschen
was anderes drunter.
Meinst du, wie viele DevOps-Engineers
es heute gibt,
die eigentlich Server-Admins sind
und ab und zu mal
im GitLab dreimal auf Next klicken?
Ja, das ist ja auch verkehrt.
Zumindest Daily Scrums
sollten so nicht gemacht werden,
weil in Daily Scrums
keiner dabei ist,
der quasi direkte Personalverantwortung
von den Leuten hat
und dementsprechend man sich
auch nicht wichtig machen muss
seinem Chef gegenüber
und weil es in Daily Scrums
auch vollkommen okay sein sollte,
mal zu sagen,
okay, gibt nichts Interessantes.
Aber ja, man hat immer Leute,
die müssen sich profilieren,
aber dafür hat man einen Scrum Master dabei
oder zumindest einen,
der ein bisschen darauf achtet,
dass die mal ihre Klappe halten
beziehungsweise nicht so lang,
nicht so ausführlich reden.
Alternativ dazu habe ich
bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber gelernt,
ihr müsst euch einen Elmo besorgen
und den zeigst du dann
in irgendeinem Team-Meeting
und Elmo steht für
Moment, ich habe vergessen.
Later, more, nee, Scrum.
Für was steht Elmo?
Enough, let's move on.
Das heißt,
wenn die zu lange labern,
hältst du Elmo hoch
und dann und dann wissen die schon,
die sollen die Klappe halten.
Klingt ein bisschen wie Kindergarten,
ist aber eine
tatsächlich praktizierte Sache
in agilen Teams.
Ich finde es gar nicht blöd,
ehrlich gesagt.
Besser, als den Leuten
ins Wort fallen zu müssen
und zu sagen,
ach, jetzt mach doch mal weiter
und dann fühlen die sich wieder angepisst.
Einfach die Karte hochhalten
und wenn dann,
wenn drei, vier Leute
die Karte hochhalten,
ist auch viel, viel besser.
Falls ich irgendwas
übersehen habe heute,
schreibt es einfach das nächste Mal
in den Chat mit EnvoBloss dabei,
dann gucke ich mir das an.
Hey, ich habe die Möglichkeit,
mich beruflich neu zu orientieren.
Ich habe richtig Bock
auf Fachinformatik
als Systemintegration.
Das würde für mich
wie die Faust aufs Auge passen,
aber meine Reha-Manager
meinen, ich bin mit 50 zu alt.
Also, du bist sicherlich
deutlich älter
als die meisten anderen Azubis,
aber ich bin der Meinung,
man ist nie zu alt dafür.
Eventuell,
je nachdem,
was du im Vorfeld
schon gemacht hast,
geht das allerdings auch,
musst du keine Ausbildung mehr machen,
das geht auch als Quereinsteiger,
wenn du schon ein bisschen Ahnung hast.
Ich meine,
ganz ehrlich,
wenn du keinen Bock
auf deinen aktuellen Job hast
und der Meinung bist,
das ist das Richtige,
ich finde, es ist nie zu spät dafür.
Aber vielleicht gibt es,
wie gesagt,
vielleicht gibt es auch
andere Möglichkeiten,
irgendwelche Umschulungen,
die schneller gehen.
Ja, und irgendwas
wollte ich noch sagen,
aber irgendwie ist mein Boomer-Brain
am Start
und ich komme nicht mehr drauf.
Ja, Nico, also,
ich denke,
dass es da nie zu spät für ist.
Die meisten Leute
haben da wahrscheinlich
keinen Bock mehr,
so nach dem Motto,
jetzt erst noch mal Ausbildung
oder irgendwie Umschulung
und dann irgendwie
zehn Jahre später in Rente,
aber hey, warum nicht?
Ich finde das gut,
gerade in der heutigen Zeit,
finde ich,
darf das ruhig alles
ein bisschen dynamischer sein
und es werden
IT-Leute händeringend gesucht.
Also vielleicht hast du auch
als Quereinsteiger eine Chance,
je nachdem,
was du für Vorkenntnisse hast.
Ich glaube, der Nico ist
schon gar nicht mehr da.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob man das Storypoint nennt,
aber wir machen,
wir machen ganz komische,
agile Sachen,
so auch Wetterkarten
und sowas,
wo man sich dann,
wo man sich dann irgendwie
so eine Sonne hinmalen muss,
wenn alles gut gelaufen ist
und so ganz, ganz weird Zeug.
So agile Sachen
haben manchmal wirklich
ein bisschen Kindergarten-Charakter.
Bist da?
Ja, also wie gesagt,
ich denke, man ist da nie zu alt für.
Und wenn das,
also ich vermute mal,
wenn du sagst,
deine Reha-Managerin
und sowas,
wahrscheinlich gibt es Probleme,
so im aktuellen Job,
den weiter zu machen,
bis man dann irgendwann
mal in Rente geht.
Weiß ich,
dass einige da Probleme haben
und ich denke,
je nachdem,
was du für Vorkenntnisse hast,
kannst du dich bestimmt
auch mal als Quereinsteiger versuchen.
Ich weiß ja nicht,
was, was da bei dir schon gibt.
Die Leute suchen händeringend IT-Leute.
Vielleicht kann man die ganze Ausbildung
auch beschleunigen.
Ach, jetzt weiß ich wieder,
was du sagen musst.
Ja, du musst, glaube ich,
nicht mehr in die Berufsschule gehen.
Ich glaube,
man kann sich von der Berufsschule
befreien lassen
ab einem gewissen Alter
und ab einer gewissen
Berufserfahrung irgendwie.
Fragt mich aber nicht genau,
wie das geht und was das ist.
Aber das habe ich gehört.
Also sprich, das kannst du,
das musst du dir,
du musst wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr damit
mit 19-Jährigen rumhocken,
die einem auf den Sack gehen.
Die labern alle.
Ganz ehrlich,
IT-Leute werden gesucht as fuck.
Und wenn du Ahnung hast,
wenn du Plan hast davon,
dann findest du auch,
findest du auch Jobs.
Ich weiß ja nicht,
was du für Vorkenntnisse hast
und wie du darauf kommst,
dass das das Richtige für dich ist.
Aber ich würde es jetzt einfach mal
so stehen lassen.
Ich meine, du wirst dir da sicherlich
schon Gedanken drüber gemacht haben.
Und insofern,
du kriegst ja vom Arbeitsamt
wahrscheinlich sogar
die Umschulung bezahlt.
Was ein bisschen schwierig ist
bei der Umschulung,
ist, du musst bei so Umschulung
vom Arbeitsamt musst du
dreiviertel Jahr Praktikum machen.
Und da ist teilweise
wirklich schwierig, was zu finden,
weil die meisten Unternehmen
gar nicht wissen,
was da eigentlich abgeht.
Du hast umfangreiches Halbwissen.
Also ganz im Ernst,
je nachdem, wie ausgeprägt das ist.
Verrätst du,
was du vorher gemacht hast,
weil du kannst das
durchaus mal probieren.
Also mal gucken,
was es bei dir in der Nähe gibt
und das mal als Quereinsteiger probieren.
Je nachdem, wie deine,
wie ausgeprägt deine Skills sind.
Magst da sicherlich Unternehmen geben,
die dich da auch als Quereinsteiger
dir eine Chance geben,
wenn du was kannst, was die brauchen.
Und IT-Leute werden eigentlich
überall händeringend gesucht.
Dass du schon ein bisschen Ahnung
von Linux und Containerisierung hast,
ist ja schon mal mehr,
als viele Windows-Apps.
Und das ist ja auch
als viele Windows-Admins
hier haben werden.
Ja, so Umschulung würde ich auch
wirklich nur als
letzte Möglichkeit machen.
Also sprich,
wenn das als Quereinsteiger nicht geht
oder wenn es keine
anderen Möglichkeiten gibt.
Aber ja, es ist schwer zu sagen.
Feinwerkmechaniker, CAD und Automatisierung.
Das klingt jetzt zumindest
nicht super IT-fern.
Ja, und ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen,
dass es die ein oder anderen
Unternehmen gibt,
die sagen wir so eher so aus dieser
oder in dieser Branche
aktiv sind,
die das sicherlich sogar
zu schätzen wissen,
dass du nicht nur ein bisschen
Ahnung von Computer-Kram hast,
sondern auch von,
tja, ich kann das schwer einschätzen,
was man da so macht,
aber auch vielleicht
von irgendwelchen Maschinen
oder von irgendwelchen
anderen Abläufen.
Die dort so passieren,
wo der 0815 Attila
eigentlich gar keine Ahnung von hat,
beziehungsweise keine
praktische Erfahrung selbst.
Da gibt es bestimmt Jobs,
die wie die Faust aufs Auge passen,
aber gut,
ich weiß ja nicht,
was man da so macht.
Also ja, keine Ahnung.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
alles ist besser.
Alles ist besser,
als irgendwie noch 15 Jahre rumgammeln
auf irgendwas,
wo man keinen Bock hat.
Deswegen, ich würde es tatsächlich
mal probieren, mich als
Quereinsteiger zu bewerben.
Ich schätze da aktuell die Chancen
besser ein, als man denkt.
Gerade wenn du sagst,
du kannst programmieren,
also du kennst dich mit
Kontainerisierung aus,
du kannst skripten,
du kannst programmieren.
Also da kann man, denke ich,
schon eine ganz ordentliche
Bewerbung zusammenzimmern.
Und viele sind heute auch
bei weitem nicht mehr
so anspruchsvoll
oder haben da irgendwelche
super abgehobenen Vorstellungen,
weil die finden ja eh keine Leute.
Also du hast,
ich, okay,
ich kann dir als Abschluss
eine Sache sagen.
Du hast jetzt aktuell
als Quereinsteiger was zu finden,
mit ein bisschen Ahnung, ja.
Es gab noch nie bessere Chancen,
als jetzt was zu finden.
Okay, Leute, ich muss ins Bett.
Aber Wochenende,
Freitag geht's weiter.
Wir gucken uns Avalonia an,
.net wird ein bisschen gebastelt,
BattleBit am Wochenende,
weil dazu muss ich noch
ein Video aufnehmen.
Ich geh jetzt pennen, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
See you.